in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12 per
to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing of bills referred to the
education committee executive session on
pending legislation may be held this is
an executive session and executive
session will be held please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate there will be no
participation of the public during an
exective session by the zoom platform or
by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the website the
notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email house committee
services at HCS ledge.
state.us in the event the public is
unable to uh listen to the meeting um
there there will be no hearings uh
during this meeting at this time I will
be when we go into hearing later on
reading this again this afternoon I want
to introduce the staff that are in on
the meeting assisting us Jennifer four
committee researcher please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting should be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please State also State
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required on the right to no
law uh mam clerk good morning
everyone uh represent Celli here in thee
room representative bone heree room
representative Allard
here representative leus here
representative mofet in the house
representative Hobson here
representative andas here home alone in
Salsbury representative
for here alone in my office
representative l here with the rest of
the committee representative sod here in
the committee room representative
Miler not here we just see it there he
is he's muted sorry uh I'm here in Kuka
in my home office by
myself
morning luno reporting from
Hopkinson hearing committee room
representative Cornell I'm here at
home representative taner I'm here at
home with my rescue dog
Raven representative
Ellis I think we just
lost
oh no who's that represent M I am here
in my basement
Studio representative
Le I am home in Jaffrey and I am alone
represent
woodcot um I think we just Lo
lost no you're muted Steve you're muted
she's there she responded but uh we
could barely hear
her repr
Ellison he's here but he's not and
representative wood is here also I
believe well let's do it up there rson
Allison did you unmute your machine yes
I did I'm present alone in my home in
conquer thank you thank you represent
[Music]
Woodcock there is no audio
audio represent Woodcock I I see you did
you unmute yourself yes he did but he
can't hear
yeah you can't hear
us
does he have headphones
in no no
okay does he his volume turned down he's
going to check on something but yeah I
flashed a paper that said is there audio
is that what that said I couldn't read
it okay representa Woodcock uh can you
hear us
now no it doesn't look like he's hearing
us
[Music]
okay and for the record I'm audio that's
correct thank you no
audio Yeah here it's just gonna flash we
have person some call him and try work
that he he's on the
phone okay and I heard my name called
clerk that ref lad is here in the
L
um was it we we are trying to call and
make connection would
represent I have just spoken to him Mr
chair and and did did you he I indicated
to him that the audio problem was on his
end and he has now uh fixed it
can you hear us I saw the finger up
there is that thanks
to than good job okay so we're all all
here uh I'd like to go ahead with the
first uh bill on the executive session I
I will also advise folks that I probably
will jump around with some of these
bills we have some fiscal notes which
are mixed in amongst others which are
not necessarily early bills we're going
to try to get these early bills I
handled uh so the first bill on the
docket today is HB 609 and I recognize
represent like is for a motion I would
like to move HB 609 ought to pass and
there there second representative Leon
second and rep representative Leon
seconds the motion representative leak
would you like to speak to your motion
yes I would I
um I would love to see this past there's
been a lot of misinformation circling
around and I just wanted to hit on a
couple of those points to clear them up
um I have heard that this ignores or
doesn't listen to or bypasses the
Educators and this actually starts with
the Educators um this might be the
teachers say we've got a great idea come
to the principal can we do this and the
principal says yeah but there's this
regulation that that you know that
preventing us from doing that so with
this he can say but there's a process
now for how to go about getting a waver
for it so they can together come up with
their plan the other thing is that I
hear is that the collective bargaining
agreement will be bypassed well this is
in the planning part of this and it's
just to say okay if you're going to plan
this you got to make sure you got all
your ducks in a row and everything works
for instance if you're thinking okay um
what as part of our plan we're going to
change the hours of operation or change
the start and end date of the school and
you don't need a waiver for that but
that might be in your collective
bargaining agreement so this gives you
the opportunity to go before you before
you do all the long process you go to
your collective bargaining unit and you
say hey we have this idea but we're
going to need to change this what do you
think and they can say well we'll pull
our members and see what they say um
it's a checkin is what it is not a we're
going to replace this but a check-in to
make sure that they're not going against
it and if they are that everybody is
with
them and even as you go through the
process that get plan's done cool go
before the school board cool they like
it uh take it to the doe the doe all
they can say is yes or no we Grant the
waivers they can't say you have to do
this they that's not what this is about
all it's doing is a abling the school to
do what they want to do right the so the
teachers can do what they want to do
because we keep hearing well the
reason um Charter Schools do so much
better than traditional Public Schools
is because they don't have to follow all
these onerous regulations well this is
here so they can say okay let's can we
please just not do this one or two so
that we can do this awesome plan that
we've come up with that's all this is
thank you very much thank you very much
uh representative uh does the second uh
who made the motion second the motion
representative Leon have uh any
discussion to add um thank you Mr chair
I believe uh representative leus hit
most of the points I do know that having
the ability to have Innovation would
have helped our schools find new
solutions to meet the needs this year
during covid uh
perhaps there's so many different ways
that they could have addressed the needs
of both the teachers and the students
had this been enabled and been Ed and I
believe that allowing our schools to ask
for this flexibility which is not forced
upon them will benefit our teachers and
our students so thank you thank you very
much okay it's now open to discussion on
the floor
Uh repres
Wood thank you good morning Mr chairman
thank you happy now that your folks can
hear me um I'd like to speak against 609
I offer this as a teacher a former
department chair and a former principal
HP 609 really is a bill that is not
needed the bill presents itself as
legislation that would provide the
opportunity for innovation in public
schools however when I questioned the
prime sponsor a week ago regarding
Innovation and I asked him was he aware
of any public school that could not
innovate or was not allowed to innovate
his answer was
no New Hampshire has been the incubator
for many Innovative schools and
according once again to the
sponsor uh and we call it we call them
chatter schools 33 of those incubators
have
Arisen this bill this bill seems to me
anyhow to be an attempt to break
teachers associations if you notice on
page2 Section 3B indicates
that this bill also and more
particularly lacks definition in many
places as regards the term public school
let me give you an
example this is qu straight from the
bill each public school that would be
affected by the plan will have the
opportunity to participate well what
does that actually mean this is just one
of the several places of lack of clarity
I just heard the representative speak
about teachers included I do not see in
that bill unless I missed it any
anywhere where identifies teachers
specifically included I don't see it
anywhere I may be wrong there seems to
be little oversight lack of local
control except for except for that
initial approval by the school
board and I may have missed a physical
note but I didn't see one and I
apologize if I missed
it and finally Mr chairman this bill in
my mind is yet just another anti-public
education Bill we have wonderful
creative Innovative teachers in our
schools all across the state and to
present this bill seems to me to be a
front to that faculty they are working
above and beyond especially now in the
innovating every day trying to make our
students successful during this crazy
year of the hybrid destruction I suggest
you again Mr chair this bill is not
needed thank you thank you very much
represent whitcock further
discussion rer uh thank you Mr chair I
would just uh uh underscore some of the
things that representative Woodcock said
uh in in bills like this that have been
taking place across the country the
little states that do have them there is
clearly a guarantee of of teacher
involvement in the creation of an
Innovative school this bill absent at
notwithstanding representative leak's
comments if in fact you really want
teachers involved in this process that
should be part of the bill which it's
not right now the other thing that I
think we need to realize is that that
there's a presumption here perhaps that
there's not Innovation going on in
schools that's that's entirely
incorrect one of the reasons why our
state has been ranked in the top five
top three in the country is because of
innovation we have kept up with the
needs of students with the needs of
Technology Etc this bill is not needed
if in fact a school a a local school
district wanted to have quote an
Innovative School they could create a
charter school that is currently in law
this bill really is not needed at this
point in time thank you thank you very
much representative Myer representative
Shaw yes um I signed on to this bill and
because I'm I'm an Innovative person I I
I like change I like things that are are
good for kids and and but after and I
apologize to the prime sponsor um
I I cannot support it at this time
because I've been thinking seriously
about it and points that representative
Woodcock brought up I was going to uh
elaborate on but uh it's fine and what
representative Miler just said uh about
the Innovation
really we have had schools in our in our
city that have adopted programs of
specific spefic Innovation and have
operated in in that Way Parker VY school
and and a couple of others so um I I I
will not support it at this time thank
you thank you very much representative
sh further
discussion is there anybody present here
that once we have a request from
represent leas again but that would be
the second time she would have
discuss represent
Tanner and Ellis thank you Mr chair I
was just wondering uh representative
Woodcock mentioned and I I noticed that
I don't have a fiscal note for this
particular bill either could someone
explain why there's no fiscal note and
and what might be uh
estimate
like us yeah I was going to touch on a
couple of those points one of them is
there's no fiscal note because there
can't be it's an innovation we don't
know what it's going to be so there's no
way of being able to assign a cost there
might be no cost there might be a cost
saving we don't know it depends upon
what the school wants to do um number
two it says as far as who it says a
public school well who is the majority
of a public school it's the teachers
right they're the Maj and the most
important part of a public school so to
me this is that's built into a public
school is the teachers and the staff and
everybody so that's all of the people at
the public school may come up with this
um there was oh what was the
other sorry there was one more point
that you guys had made that I was going
to explain why it's worded the way it is
oh I know what it was not all schools
want to become Charter Schools they
don't want to do make the big change
they just want to want to waiver for a
few things and this is more a procedure
than anything to help with how you would
go about doing that to make it easier to
say do this and then this and then this
to to make it easier to be able to lay
out a plan and make sure you've hit all
the points um in order to wave just a
few things in order order to have a plan
that the teachers and administrators
would like to try in their school that's
thank you very much represent leas for
responding regarding that fiscal
question Ellison had his hand represent
Ellison thank you Mr chairman uh I I'd
like to get some more clarification if I
can on the uh collective bargaining
issue that's been brought up it would
seem to me that if a school decided or
wanted to go with an Innovative school
and wanted to pay teachers less than
what they were what was in the
collective bargaining agreement at this
point that the entire package would have
to go back to the bargaining unit which
would be the teachers to be voted upon
uh I I just want to be sure that that's
the
understanding it's my to to and you
respond to that represent Allison it's
my understanding that in the bill it
specifies that the collective bargaining
agreement in effect for personnel at the
public school that would need to be
waved uh in the public school or excuse
me waved or modified for the public
school to implement its intended or
identified Innovation so that as I'm
reading it that would have to come back
to the uh collective bargaining
agreement and that would have to be
waved um U by the folks involved with
the collector barbing agreement uh prior
to uh moving forward I'll go ahead and
uh recognize representative cordelli
thank you um thank you Mr chairman um on
that point I would say that it's in that
section of the uh
legislation uh as a matter of
transparency as part of the plan if the
Administration has negotiated anything
with the bargaining unit it should be
part of the plan so that uh the school
board knows about it there's a public
hearing everybody knows about it it's
transparency that's why it's there uh
secondly in terms of um the fiscal note
this is basically enabling legislation
it's enabling uh a school district to uh
request waivers uh that's s simply it
um I would think that the situ ation
we're in over the next decade uh looking
at enrollment declines of 20,000 or more
students uh school districts are going
to have to change and modify this bill
will enable them to do that don't need
that uh to uh get waivers from current
rules so that they can innovate and also
realize cost savings as we approach or
as we're in the midst of a declining
enrollment in the state du to
demographics okay thank you very much uh
at this point in time on this bill I
want to make clear that we have not
received a fiscal note regarding this
from
Boe um who was next Le and then Corell
okay represent LE uh thank you Mr
chairman um so I just want to uh make
sure I understand so
I know uh my colleague representative Le
has said that um you know teachers could
propose this Etc could conceivably a uh
single or two people who are not
Educators at all or are not teachers
let's say uh propose this and uh
persuade the school board to go ahead
with it without consulting teachers in
advance can they do that a yes or
no represent uh Corell or whomever yeah
Whoever has yeah um clearly in the bill
there is a local planning process uh any
plan that is originated has to go
through the the school board and a
public hearing wasn't the question
that's again the question is though can
a plan be proposed without having prior
consultation with the teachers yes or
no I would think that any plan uh
proposed by anyone in the school is
going to go through
uh the administration and the school
board so therefore the teachers do not
need to be consulted is that correct
approval pardon is that what you're
requesting that uh a plan has to get
Union approval is that I didn't say
Union uh I'm not saying Union I'm just
asking teachers I'm just asking teachers
Mr representative
cordelli okay let's go on with I'm not
Excuse me yes I'm not finished no I was
going to say if you had another question
oh thank you yes I do um so um if a plan
is put forward and receives a Department
of Education approval and they're
allowed to go forward can the bargaining
unit or the agent representing the um
employees in the school district uh
affected or where whose contract may
have Provisions modified or waved can
they thereby reject it and thereby uh
halt the
plan yes go ahead
um there's several steps in the process
yeah school board approval a public
hearing as part of that process it goes
to the Department of Education for
review and and comment um and any
suggestions on improving the plan um I
think we heard testimony uh from was it
this um the department or the Board of
Education that they have no um ability
to to okay a plan that affects a
bargaining unit um without uh agreement
on the a part of the bargaining unit
because it goes through the department
then to the State Board of Education
where there is another public hearing
before the uh state board uh votes on
the waiver
request so in other words if there is no
uh prior let's say agreement on
modifying or waving provisions of a
collective bargaining agreement let's
just say the plan went was put forward
without the prior agreement um in place
um with the bargaining unit agent then
therefore um the bargaining unit could
still simply afterwards by rejecting The
Proposal halt the plan is that correct
I'm just trying to make sure I
understand the process here I think your
assumption is that um the uh
Administration and the school board um
are going to go forward with a plan that
modifies the uh collective bargaining
agreement without um uh going back and
negotiating that that change um I think
you in that case you would have uh
issues with the Department of Labor as
well possibly yeah yeah I mean I I agree
with you I think it would be uh foolish
to go ahead and do it although I have
seen stranger things in this world so um
I cannot rule it out I I have one other
just question here and that is um at the
end of the bill near the end of the bill
the department finds the Innovation plan
performance is not satisfactory they
shall notify the local uh board and the
State Board what are the metrics that
are to be used if rules are being
waved in other words to measure whether
or not an innovation is succeeding or
not uh go ahead yeah thank you chairman
um there are several things mentioned in
the plan um excuse me in the legislation
um I think the metrics are what is put
forward in the plan what are the
expectations um in the plan that has
been approved um are they expecting um
cost savings are they uh expecting um
greater uh achievement uh scores uh
those types of things and that's what uh
You' be looking at is going back to the
plan what did the plan wish to
accomplish and those would be the
metrics that you look at
thank you very much okay thank you thank
you rep Corell re
Cornell I just want to speak to rep
woodcock's statement that it's not
needed because New Hampshire allows
Innovation I just want to mention
Manchester High School West steam
program which is an Innovative program
within West High School where students
um apply to be in it um and it has
Partnerships with local community
colleges local businesses um and it's an
Innovative program that emphasizes stem
subjects within the school um so all it
needed was Schoolboard approval to do
that um there was no legislation needed
to do that and they still have to do the
requirements for graduation and meet
everything else but it's a concentration
within the school so I I don't think
this legislation is needed in order to
do this it's just the willingness of the
school to get together and plan it
that's all thank you represent Mullen
thank you Mr chair um I I am going to
ask for a point of clarification I guess
from representative cordelli um on page
four of the original legislation in the
section that is entitled on line 19
Innovation plans waiver of regulatory
requirements uh Roman 1 says upon the
designation of an innov ation school or
school zone the State Board shall wave
compliance with any administrative rules
specified at the local District
level uh that to to me uh representative
cordelli is a very broad statement and
I'm wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit on whether or not this means
that once an Innovative plan is adopted
then the state board will automatically
wave all aspects of administrative rules
for the local school district is that
correct yes go ahead yes go ahead thanks
for the question um I do not believe
that is correct uh the plan that is put
forward for approval at the local board
uh department and state board level
um uh indicates the regulations that are
to be W and that is what is being
dressed in the section that you
referen thank you further question
represent M uh just a followup to that
so representative cordelli when it says
the administrative rules specified at in
the Local District plan is that in
reference to the Innovative School plan
or is it the Local District plan for the
delivery of public education it is in
the Innovation plan put forward by the
local
board okay uh thank you that was unclear
thank thank you further further
questions represent alloy thank you Mr
chairman um I just wanted to state that
uh I I do support this bill and I
support it uh because I find it uh
rather
innocuous uh I don't see it as a threat
to anything that's going on currently
and it may open the doors uh for further
uh Innovation down the road having said
that uh I would also want to acknowledge
the points made by representative
Woodcock and and representative Miler uh
that there is no shortage of innovation
currently ongoing in New Hampshire
schools and uh there's something to be
proud of uh this bill
just give someone the opportunity to
keep that ball roll thank thank you very
much further questions uh represent luno
uh thank you very much Mr chair and this
is probably more of a point of
information but um I was wondering if um
uh if we could have the um the results
or the tallies on the um what what I
would sort of refer to as the blue
sheets and um and the my second part of
my point of information
is um how do members of the public have
access to the blue sheets and to the uh
list of people that are signed up to
testify I know we've got a hearing
coming up this
afternoon the blue sheets are for if
you're talking about for hearings that
are coming up uh we will be provided
that information around noon time on on
the most current they're constantly
changing uh so rather getting a sheet at
this moment uh we prefer to receive that
and have asked to receive the most
current information we have prior to
starting the hearing no I'm I'm I'm the
blue sheet I'm talking about is is on
609 relative to this bill part of the
record what's that they're all part of
the record the
number could you could you read out that
number because we don't have access to
it we we do not have that file in front
of us right now that is upstairs as
we've had in the past P um uh we've had
that available to us but electronically
we have not been provided that
information here it is available and we
will get that to you but wouldn't would
isn't that important before a
vote Yes we we read the results
following the hearing so you should have
that
information and what were those
results you should have that information
they were read I don't have those
results in front of me but they were
read so um I that I think that's the
best we can answer that question at this
time okay and then how do members of the
public have access to this information
and particularly people that are signed
up to testify since that's a a related
Luna we have had our hearing the public
has had the opportunity to register
their positions this is an executive
session which deals with this
committee thank you Mr chair hand
raised represent Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman just to follow up
and represent Luna's question I'd be
very interested to know and I don't have
the count uh it would seemed to me that
the clerk would have the count from the
last meeting um I think the on all our
bills it would be wonderful for us and
the public to know what the yes SN and
neutral are particularly us on uh Zoom
who aren't there so if it's possible to
get there from the clerk before the
votee it'd be much appreciated thank
you you can get that information
directly from uh the clerk of the house
Paul Smith has all that information
available M Mr Mr chair I have an answer
to that question excuse me hold on a
second please is uh is representative is
is Paul Smith available to answer that
question yes he has his hand I'm going
to recognize the clerk of the house call
Smith one
second
okay go ahead Mr
clerk uh thank you uh Mr chair and
members of the committee um uh the the
question has has come up about uh the
blue sheets and that sort of thing so uh
to be clear um we are continually
working on this project because as you
know this we're we're we're living in a
in a different time here and and uh
everything we're doing is sort of uh re
uh
you know rewriting the book uh that
being said the um the list of people
testifying and those signing the blue
sheets are in fact the same um and we
are now going to be um because of
because of how we're doing this um and
and the fact that we have had uh so many
people continue to sign up during the
hearings and that sort of thing we have
changed the process such that anybody
who is seeking to sign up um needs to do
so by 8 o'clock the morning of the
hearing um and that is when the chair
will get the list for the day that being
said just as in a normal setting when we
have um uh public hearings and members
of the public wish to testify from the
audience um the they are allowed to
raise their hands from uh the the
audience position in this case and um
they will be able to uh be called on by
the chair in that setting uh the blue
sheet practice in the past has has been
that usually at the end of the public
hearing the chair reads uh the numbers
or the the persons who signed in uh
stating their positions for the record
um in some of those instances we have
had um you know many hundreds of people
um signing up uh some from as far away
as California and the like uh and and
registering their opinions and uh they
have been reading those numbers uh into
into the record um as far as the list
being available we are working on how to
make that available to the entire public
uh the um
information is going to be readily
available to all members of the
committee um the I I do have uh Ju Just
on this particular bill I did I was able
to uh pull up and and um do a quick
tally and again this is very quick uh
but it looks like there were about 48
opposed and one in favor um of those
that that uh did uh register on the bill
uh so I did want to just clarify that
that we are continuing to work on this
to make this uh uh more available to you
as the committee but also to the public
as well thank you very much uh I clarify
Mr Smith yes go ahead H thank you for
taking my question um Mr House clerk I
I'm wondering you said did for
clarification did you say that we will
now be um asked to call on people from
the audience in a regular hearing would
that not have been the case I'm just um
though representative Hobson to be to be
clear in in a normal situation a member
from the audience could fill out a pink
card and send it up to the committee
chair uh and be allowed to participate
because um because of the the form uh
that we have been using for signups um
has been uh sort of uh a live document
that's that's been updated it's been
changing the order in which uh people
are are getting and unfortunately the
chair have a the chairs have a static
document and so there have been people
that have not been called on so in order
to make that uh policy more uniform we
are asking um that all members who are
wishing to testif ify on legislation uh
do so ahead of the the hearing and that
that list will be provided to the chair
and then as the public hearing is going
on any member of the public May raise
their hand uh and it is up to the chair
uh at the appropriate time after going
through the list to recognize those
persons thank you thank you very much Mr
Smith uh I'm ready to get back to this
bill that we're discussing right now HB
um further uh
represent thank you Mr chair I actually
had a question for the the the clerk of
the house if I could just a
followup is it regarding this bill it is
regarding yes it is in regards to this
Bill
yes uh Mr Smith are you there yes sir uh
thank you Mr clerk um so you stated that
um the number the signup sheet on this
bill was currently I believe you said 48
opposed and one in
support uh that is correct the uh um the
the quick tally that I was able to just
do a very quick count off the top of my
screen here uh that's what I came up
with
and so that's just from
today no sir that would be that would be
from those that that signed up on the um
for I'm sorry yes for the uh just for
today not for the uh the hearing that
was held last week on this bill this
this would have been uh from last week
the the other uh thank you for actually
clarifying this because I I I do want to
clarify as well that we are now also
closing off the blue sheet uh the day of
the hearing um prior to uh basically
yesterday uh we people had the ability
to log in and continue to update their
opinions ahead um after the hearing had
been concluded as you know we don't
allow for that during the normal course
of of the hearing um so we we have
amended our our policy to the day of the
hearing at by the by midnight of the day
of the hearing we are going to close off
the blue sheet um so that people cannot
continue to sign up so so I thought I
heard 8 a no no I'm sorry that so
testifying and blue sheet is is
different things so if somebody is
wishing to testify um they have to get
their their testimony uh their their pin
card filled out by 8 A.M the day of the
blue sheet will remain open for people
to register their opinions through the
hearing to the conclusion of the hearing
day and then just one final question if
I might Mr
chair um thank you Mr clerk um
so the blue sheet quote unquote blue
sheet from um last week's hearing on HB
609 um I believe the numbers were read
at the end of the hearing um but is
there any way if it's been updated um
and allowed you know that it's been open
for people to sign in either in support
or in opposition to the bill is there
any way that we as a committee can check
on what that update was um you know what
the final tally was before that was
closed off um I the the short answer is
I don't know uh the answer to that I
don't know how many had signed in uh at
that time or if people did sign in
afterward um so if if if the clerk has
the um the number uh in in her record I
I I'm not entirely sure thank you thank
you very much uh represent LE and Smith
and and I'm I I am just seeing I'm sorry
that that uh the the chair um has texted
me that he has got uh completely
different numbers than I do because he
he has a he has a much greater form um
than I do so uh and I I am just looking
um at a snapshot so he he has a much
more complete list so again thank you
for that Mr chair thank you um I I'm
going to try to move on to discussion uh
Beyond this particular point I think
we've been uh been given a thorough
explanation by the house clerk uh we've
had opportunity to ask questions of you
we're going to move on now are there any
other positions from folks who have not
yet had an opportunity to
discuss then I'm gonna call
and yeah I I do I do have a a
clarification just on the last point my
notes indicated that you read at the end
of the session last time that there were
20 that supported this POS this bill and
400 that were opposed that's what my
notes say I I stand to be corrected but
that's that's what my notes
say I I do not have that information in
front of me so that you you presented
that so um it'll be part of the the
record uh going forward now if there's
no other person that has any further
discussion on that who has already had
an opportunity I'm going to ask that the
clerk um move forward with uh
identifying the bill and
going forward with the
vote this is a vote on a toath I I just
want to say something in
my oh that's we got
it
um this has been extremely confusing
because I have
not uh had a lot of of this information
given to me or or anything so what I'm
going to do from now on is make sure
that I keep a record after the meeting
so if this question comes up at
executive commit uh I will have whatever
the the um the chairman reads I had no
idea that this was going to be something
that people were going to be asking
after executive session so from now on I
will have a record um
after each U um hearing that we have so
that this will be readily available uh
for you so so with that thank you uh so
we're going to move ahead here with
House Bill 609 this is an act relative
to The Innovation schools uh we have a
motion on the floor ought to pass
presented by represent leus and second
by represent Leon uh Madam clerk would
you please take the role yes
representative
cordelli yes representative bone yes
representative Bard yes representative
lakas yes representative Moffett
yes representative Hobson yes
representative
Andress yes representative Ford yes
representative Leon yes representative
St yes representative Miler no luno no
representative Shan no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner
no Ellison no president Mullen no blade
noid Woodcock
noid black
yes
well we will have a Minority Report and
uh representative Woodcock will provide
that report to you Mr chair thank you
very much represent Myer well do Mr
chairman okay Woodcock uh what we're
trying to do is committee reports once
called blurs in as soon as you can get
please um if you take 24 hours that's
fine I send it electronically to me and
same to represent like us
majority report thank you Mr chairman
just clarification do you want that do
you want that sent to your legislative
email or a different one yeah send it to
the legislative account that I have
ledge. state. okay thank you and these
reports are then read by myself as Myer
has done in the past they and signed off
and then it's uh sent to our research
people to look for technical type uh
issues maybe and wording Etc and then it
goes on to to the clerk and the speaker
of the house where the speaker looks
them over and and then they're put in
the
calendar thank you thank you very much
uh we will move on to our our next bill
that's going to come up today and um I'm
jumping to another fiscal note which we
have uh HP
497 497 is a bill which exempts the
chief administrative officer uh I
recognize representative Leon for a
motion uh thank you than you Mr chair I
would like to move House Bill 497 in
expedient to legislate and
representative B for a a second and
represent B second so we have a motion
on the floor on HB 497 as itl made by
representa Leon and second by
representative bone uh represent Leon do
you have
discussion thank you Mr chair uh this
bill was brought forth and it appears to
mainly represent just one School
District that has interest in doing this
we heard from the school administrators
Association that this is not actually
needed that there's already a good
market for uh for the superintendent and
that this is not actually something that
is needed across the state this is
something where perhaps with Innovation
schools this could be a waiver to allow
a super a superintendent to have a
waiver from this compulsory uh from the
participation in the retirement system I
I thank you very much repres made the
second any no thank you is there
discussion amongst other members of the
committee represent L uh thank you Mr
chair I would simply note that I would
support the uh motion of inexpedient to
legislate on this um the uh New
Hampshire retirement system although it
took no position made clear that while
an employees contributions can be moved
uh the employer's contribution cannot
those go into a the broader based State
account um and I just don't think that
this is uh necessary at this time
nothing prevents a school district right
now from uh offering to a potential
superintendent um not just simply the
contribution into the nhrs but um to
offer an additional contribution into a
private account of the uh potential
superintendent's choice so uh I don't
find that this is necessary at this
point Thank you thank you very much
further
discussion do you see anything there and
there's no further discussion outside or
in this room so with that uh Madam clerk
uh we're going to move forward with uh
this bill uh HB 497 a bill which deals
with the allowing a school district to
exempt its chief administrative officer
from compulsory participation in the
retirement
system and the motion is to
itl mam cler yes representative
yes representative B yes representative
callard yes representative leus yes
representative mofet yes representative
Hobson yes representative Andress yes
representative Ford
yes representative Lan
yes representative sod yes
representative
miler
you're
muted yes
sorry represent lumo yes represent no
representative
Cornell
no representative
Tanner
yes yes Mullen yes representative Le
yes Woodcock
yes
182 repres oh I'm
sorry yes still
182 good that's modern
math okay the result of that is I and
the pass with a vote of
18-2 uh it's it's
I'd rather that not go on consent we'll
put it on the regular
calendar okay the next bill which we're
going to come up with moving down
looking at the FN bills is HB
9696 HB 96 is a bill establishing the
office of School counseling and
psychology establishing the position of
school counselor coordinator and making
appropriation therefore I would like to
recognize represent
B thank you i' make a motion of
itl and representative leus is
recognized for a second I second the
motion thank you very much I apologize
for the delay there you know I need a
course inmans ship can't read my own
writing
here okay thank you so with that uh does
the maker of the motion care to uh
discuss the yeah yes represent B just
briefly the Department of Education at
any department they should be the
ones to in their budget State what they
need money for we should not be telling
Department of Ed you have to have
a counselor you have to have
psychologist you have to have it's for
them to decide put in their budget and
submit it at the budget I don't think in
any Department we should be telling that
department how to Michael manage their
their Department it should be up
to the commissioner of that department
or others it should not be our job thank
you thank you very much represent like
this yes the last time this was up when
we did this I voted for it um because I
really really like especially the Career
and Technical development aspects of
that because I know a lot of um school
districts and counselors don't actually
know what's available however at this
time with the fiscal with what's going
on in our state in the state budget and
whatever I think this is not the time to
pass this I think money that we have
could be used better elsewhere um not to
say that if it comes up again in a in a
year and um you know the state doing
better our economy is doing well I might
change you know I might go back at that
point thank you very much further
discussion from members of the
committee okay I I I'd like to ask I'll
recognize representative Cornell I'd
like to ask people to you know there's a
little place where you can put up your
hand by way of technology that will help
me on my screen and seeing those that
would like to speak thank you
Cornell um I am the spons main sponsor
of this bill and it was passed last time
18 by two and I don't think the needs um
described by the bill have gone away in
fact I think it's even more important
now that school counselors psychologists
social workers um career counselors have
someone specific in the Department of
Education that they know that they can
call and get an answer to their
questions I think the department now is
overburdened with all kinds of um
different things and I don't think
there's anyone there that has time to
specialize in what school counselors um
need at this time um this is a position
that was previously funded and filled
and it's been ba vacant since
2018 so it would just be putting back
into place what it has previously been
there and again I think it's going to be
once after what we're going through and
what we're going through now this
position's going to be needed even more
than it was
before thank you very much
representative Cornell Thank you
represent Shaw yes thank you H I
couldn't agree more with representative
Cornell um I this position has been
funded and was eliminated or was Lo
overlooked or whatever or drao and at
this particular time having worked with
uh many kids in the last year or so and
and
months this the need for counseling and
the need for a consistency around the
state with counseling is more important
than ever and I think this position is
worthy of
of
appropriation it's worthy of
reinstatement and um it it certainly
should not be overlooked just because of
a budgetary concern and there are many
times when we pass bills that are um
that put of uh that sort of uh uh or a
mandate to uh a department uh we do that
many times so that isn't even an
argument with me I think this position
is highly important and and should we
should pass this thank you thank you
very much representative sha further
discussion represent Miler thank you Mr
chair just to underscore what
representative Corell and Cornell and
Shaw just said but I'd also like to
address represent B's comment uh there's
a presumption in in his comment is that
the uh Department understands what needs
to be done out in the field that's not
all that's not always the case in this
instance this was brought to us by those
who are practicing psych counselors and
the need for this and I think it's a
responsibility of this committee to
listen to what the field is saying and
to act accordingly when there is a need
notwithstanding what the department
feels thank you thank you very much
further discussion
repr Woodcock thank you Mr chairman I'll
make this uh brief I do agree with
representative Shaw as a co-sponsor I I
just want to reiterate there is no time
more necessary than now look around
we're in a covid faculty students
families they're all overstressed this
is the time we need to have some
leadership from the top that's all we're
trying to do there's no more important
time than right now thank you Mr
chairman very much further discussion R
Mullen Brett Mullen thank you uh Mr
chair uh just to refresh people's
memories uh the last time that we dealt
with this bill was last session and a as
representative Cornell uh mentioned it
left us with an 182 ought to pass
recommendation when it went to finance I
believe uh and I'm correct me if I'm
wrong if anyone remembers otherwise but
I believe that Finance uh may have made
the recommendation to the Department of
Education that they go ahead and put
this in their budget as representative
boam
suggested uh so my vote for this bill
this morning will be simply that I
disagree with the decision uh of the doe
not to put this in its budget this time
around because I think that we all
recognize that social emotional learning
and mental health of our students right
now during this pandemic time ought to
be front and center thank you thank you
very much representative Mullen further
discussion do we have anybody that you
see repres represent like us yeah I just
have a question um don't the school
count guidance counselors have a
organization or multiple organizations
that they can turn for this type of
question that won't cost the state
money does anybody know who's that to
anybody in the Comm anybody who knows
the
answer they they do have a an
association and it like the LI
Librarians often times work with various
local associations we have one in the
Upper Valley which involves both Vermont
and New Hampshire and when Librarians
have a issue they especially the public
Li Librarians working with schools that
issue sometimes is brought up there or
people have a a contact number they call
to get advice speech pathologists
throughout the state oftentimes chat
with each other and they also have their
National Asher which they can contact
there are those associations that are
available to help with specific problems
and I know they all do that uh folks
often times will call Nea for support
and and and get support on a particular
issue whether it being instruction
curriculum or some other aspect of
education so that's available I I think
what this bill is trying to look at is
setting a person like this available on
the department level thank you thank you
repr Mullen yeah just to address uh
thank you Mr chair just to address
representative leakes's uh question uh I
I was a member of the New Hampshire uh
School Counselors Association for many
many many years uh they do not have
supervisory capacity over any people
employed as school counselors in New
Hampshire and uh they certainly would
not have uh as much regulatory
information as somebody who was working
under the
direct supervision of the Department of
Education I mean I think what we're
looking for in this position is someone
who not only knows about School
counseling but also sits at the
table in decision making at the
department of Ed as uh issues are coming
up about what to do Statewide thank you
further
discussion see any hands up not seeing
any hands up I will call we'll call the
motion or go forward with the motion
this is uh HB 96 establishing the office
of school coun and psychology
establishing the position of school
counsel coordinator and making an
appropriation therefore um and the
motion is
itl mam
clerk yes representative
Celli
yes representative B yes representative
palard yes representative leakas yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes yes
representative Andress yes
representative Ford yes
representative yes representative sod
yes representative
Miler no Representative luno no
represent Shaw no representative Cornell
no representative
taner no
repr Ellison no Mullen
no representative Blake
noes
no representa lad
yes
119k you Mr chair uh representative
Cornell will do the Minority Report on
this thank you very
much I already set
you okay
yeah please as I mentioned earlier all
all committee reports be majority or
minority should be sent to myself and
hopefully within the next day um if you
can't do it give me a call and uh I
might be able to help you out with a
little bit of more time but uh things
it's coming down to crunch time here
please and I'd like to save our
committee assistant uh not having to do
all this at the last moment uh going on
to the next uh bill which is a there's a
financial note but I'm going to take the
other bill first HB 214 this is school
building Aid uh remember we both had 214
and 594 FN School building Aid bills uh
the hearing at the same time for both um
so what I'd like to do is turn to
214 first
please M Mr chair point of uh point of
clarification here is it your intent to
deal with 214 and then 594 subsequent to
this since they are both dealing with
the same topic what I will do represent
Myer is that I'm going to shortly hand
that gavel over to um represent
cordelli uh and uh I will be we'll be
acting separately on both bills but they
are both very related yes so um
that's how I intend to go through this
seeing they are separate bills um and
unless there's you know an option to
amend them into one bill that Amendment
would be brought forward on the bill so
so so sure sure intends to deal with 214
and then right after that uh
594 yes we will have thank you we'll
have a motion on
214 and then we will go on to um and
take action on on that and then go on to
the lad Bill 594 thank you welome so
with that I'm handing the gamble over to
represent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman um so uh
Mr
chair yes yeah I'd be happy to make the
motion of ought to pass on this I'm
sorry I was about to call on
um chairman lad for his motion since he
handed the gum
okay okay thank you for your offer
though thank you very much uh for the
record U I'd like to uh recommend that
this bill be
retained retained second second second
from uh R
Valor uh any discussion uh from the
maker of the motion yes thank very much
um rep uh HB 214 School building a is a
bill which is dear dear to my heart we
we've had this come forward year after
year and when it hits the next committee
Finance uh it's always addressed in a a
finance perspective uh taking the and
paying off the tail which uh for f
fiscal year 23 it would be $32 million
and then uh looking at what applications
we may have for school building a
and adding that cost into it so it's
never been fully up to the $50 million
that this bill speaks to no less than 50
million uh last year there were three
bills which were added on top of that
the year before that we had one
emergency bill with
inale my recommendation to retain is
done simply because uh reality tells me
that it's going to be probably uh
decimated at the next level in finance
that's my own projection it's of course
it's not reality uh you know yet but
that's what I believe will probably
happen uh I therefore see the best
opportunity for us to really address the
issues that are coming up with um School
building Aid is to have a thorough
discussion on how we are going to fund
School building Aid how much we're going
to fund it for and then looking at all
statutory
language uh regarding the application
process the application process right
now is a very convoluted process which
deals with the applications coming in
with site design plans you have the
letter of intent you have the
application deadline you have then the
deadline in which a recommendation has
to be made by the department that
recommendation goes forward to the
school building authority the school
building authority then uh sends their
recommendation back to the state Board
of Education and that has to be released
by January the 15th um to the various
publics that are those that put the
applications in and so they can then go
to town vote it's a process which has uh
worked with just three bills here one of
those three applications this last year
one of those applications was uh did uh
um generate a lot of discussion that was
the U school building a project to the
district which I represent hay
Woodsville
area the the statute that came into
conflict was they the part that we're
dealing with the school building
authority and what the Matrix is what
the criteria they're using to assess and
determine whether this re this
recommendation coming out of the
department if is U uh following uh or
addressing issues that they have in
terms of bonding ability other issues
and also the meeting the standards and
the criteria which we have set up in
statute that must be looked
at the the poal for us to uh or the need
I should say to really look at this
whole process now it's important we need
need to address this time frame frame
the the application process where our
priorities are I I feel this time I
we've learned a lot from Co we know that
there's a lot of issues many issues
dealing with various systems within
buildings be it hbac be it acoustical be
it lighting uh Etc we know that there's
Esser monies available which are upwards
towards 150 plus million dollar and and
those monies are available for use um in
schools school to read items 13 14 and
15 in the Esser report school facility
repairs and improvements to enable
operation of schools to reduce risk risk
of virus transmission exposure to
environmental ha haard and to support
student health so if the facility
repairs can be used for those areas uh
for inspection testing maintenance
repair replacement upgrade of projects
to improve the indoor air quality and
school facilities um and other
activities that are necessary to
maintain the operation of and continuity
of services and local education agencies
and continue to employ existing staff of
the local Education
Agency so the monies uh are can be uh
supplant various aspects uh of what
we're doing um to build a whole new
building though that will happen with
the eser monies we maybe perhaps some
renovation projects could occur when it
comes to air systems Etc I feel strongly
that there is such a need to relook that
it has to be done immediately I was
attempted to put in a an amendment to
this bill which would establish a
committee to look at that made up of
Representatives and Senate but that
would take until probably the fall to
get it going with a short period of time
to investigate that I'd rather have a
subcommittee put together uh where we
can have active membership uh and
involve it also with folks from finance
and have a report come out from that
subcommittee so we can take action in
the second year of the vium so that
concludes my remarks Mr chair
thank you very much Mr chair would the
um maker of the second uh wish to
comment uh thank you Mr chairman I doubt
there's any eloquence that I could
add uh thank you for your brevity um I
see a hand up with representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and uh and
thank you very much uh chairman lad for
um for your your very um important
remarks surrounding the uh the need for
um for building Aid and for um for
making uh improvements to the building
aid program I think as we um as we saw
from uh from director Clark from uh from
the Department there's over um uh $200
million dollar worth of uh of projects
that have uh have uh filed for Grant
applications for just the first year of
the banum
fy22 and um and
um in those projects um the uh the
building aid grant value is over $
hundred million so I think what we're
seeing right now and and I think this
this you know alludes to um to the
chair's remarks is that over the 10-year
moratorium period we've seen a uh We've
obviously seen a number of projects
number of uh school districts go ahead
with projects because they couldn't wait
but we've also seen a tremendous
pipeline develop where uh where projects
need to um are are really are really
critical and um and you know according
to director Clark's uh information that
she presented in in the um um very
detailed handout these range from from
you know classroom projects to air
quality to energy to a variety of
different um uh different things and I
certainly recognize the chair's um
intention and I and I believe it it's
certainly sincere to uh to to continue
to work on this issue and not let um and
not let a a good bill a bill that I was
certainly willing to to recommend a to
pass on um uh get uh get stuck in the
finance committee but um but that said
you know we we uh we have another bill
coming up as well and I know this isn't
the exact session on that and I'm not
asking for that but um but uh given the
uh given the urgency um perhaps the
second Bill 594 is something that that
this committee might um might uh not
mind moving towards finance and letting
it uh uh be committed there and uh and
it gives the opportunity to uh to sort
of have our cake and eat it too number
one have a bill that's retain that we
can continue to work on and use as a
vehicle in um in the the second year of
the bium but also stress the importance
of the building aid program for uh for
districts um uh around the state and um
and and the importance of changes to the
building aid program to be able to
address the hundreds of millions of
dollars in Project backlog and be able
to do that um within a a financially
sustainable and responsible Manner and
when we do get to 594 I do intend to
offer an amendment that um that that
essentially merges 594 with the uh with
the changes representative lad put into
house bill 214 so it would in fact have
the same fiscal um uh uh level the 50
million which would include Capital
project grants plus the the tail the
ongoing tail obligation so so it would
it would essentially combine both those
those bills so um so anyway I just
wanted to put uh put that out there that
I think this is a this is a very
important both these bills are very
important and I think we've got a a good
strong opportunity here to um to get
something done uh this um this bium uh
but also maybe uh uh in this first year
of the bium as well so thank you very
much Mr chair representative pH thank
you Mr
chair this is my seventh term here and
over in the past it's always been a
policy of some kind you have multiple
bills on the same subject you try to get
together and come up with one bill some
years ago it was a homeschooling Bill we
had a bunch from them and we retained
them and came up with one good bill so
the same thing here they're parts of
both bills that may be good that may be
bad and I
think retaining to come up because we
don't have time to make a subcommittee
now to do it uh is a is a good idea we
need to retain it and then come up with
something that may get through the
second committee and that's one of the
issues we have let's you know not waste
time pass this and finance is gonna
because nothing's going to change
they're gonna say we only have X amount
of money and that's what we have um
so maybe a good idea I know our school
district is looking for building ha
because I told them you're not on the
list and they thought they were but but
sort of shock but anyway yeah all lot of
school districts need money they need a
new school
but right now we can't afford the thing
and if they didn't mess it up some years
ago and bonding the whole issue we
probably wouldn't have this problem
today so with that thank
you thank you very much representative
and next repr miles uh thank you Mr
chairman um for those members who are
new to this committee you need to
realize that this issue of building Aid
has been around for since I've been in
the legislature we've looked at this
time and time again the school funding
commission looked at this in depth this
summer and came up with a very similar
recommendation that is in this
particular Bill uh I will vote to retain
this
bill but not the next bill
because it's my belief that based upon
the data that we have received from
input from variety of different sources
that we cannot continue to kick this can
down the road which has been the problem
with school funding Aid since I've been
in the
legislature so notwithstanding uh
representative lad's comments because I
I understand those comments but we need
to move on this bill because we've got
we've got school districts out there
that are in dire need of this fund and
it's time for the state to step up and
begin to to look at this so I will
retain I will vote to retain this bill
but I will not do that in the next bill
which I think combines this bill with a
much broader look at how the funding can
be dispersed uh in the next Bill thank
you very
much thank you
representative um do I see any other
comments from the committee have
we do have one
attendee um seeing none uh I thank you
and I would uh call on the clerk to uh
do a roll uh for House Bill 214 relative
to school building Aid Brant and the
motion and the motion is
uh representa cell representative
lad yes representative B
um wait a minute representative B yes
representative Allard yes representative
L yes representative Mett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Andress yes representative Ford yes
representative Lon yes representative s
yes representative Miler yes
representative Luna
yes representa shy yes representative
Cornell yeses Tanner yes represent
Ellison yes Mullen yes L yes woodcot yes
Celli
yes thank you very
much okay thank you very much folks I'm
going to take the gble back here and
we're going to move into HB 594
FN um and before I take a motion I want
to open this up to discussion and during
this discussion I will not be taking or
accepting motions at this time I'd like
to have just an honest open discussion
on
594 and I'll explain my reasoning for
that I understand that I have not not
seen it at this point in time that there
is an amendment for that bill it's
coming from I believe represent luno uh
that it's I would assume it's very
similar to what 214 is um okay so that
that that's included now there in
594 um I have there are certain issues
that are associated with
594 which I have some concern with and
remember we're in that discussion the
ultimate goal of 594 is an excellent
goal and we need to move forward in
something whether it be now or you after
we've had an opportunity to do some work
I'll tell you the areas which I have
concerned with and then we can have the
discussion and both sides can get
involved with this I on this particular
bill it's not really a a one side versus
another side it's about schools and
school facilities I am concerned with
the no no longer having the
80% up front for the school district and
backlogging some of the cost of that and
putting that onto the school districts
in terms of uh interest costs they're
going to pay seeing that they're going
to have to take out some kind of a a tan
or something to a bond which is going to
pay for what would be coming from the
state that the over the period of the 20
years that's one concern I have the
other concern I have is who actually
approves
the uh application that comes in is it
the Department of Education I've read
the bill where it says the Department of
Education shall make the grant but it
doesn't say approve what's the Defence
of make um is it the state board that
approves maybe that's explained
somewhere in the bill you know I read it
very very late at night so I I could be
wrong but that's how I'm seeing it the
other issue which I'm seeing is the
school building author which we had in
the in current uh statutory line which
is a check and balance I don't know if
that check and balance has really worked
the way we intend for it to be but I
believe that there needs to be a process
which there's a check and balance in
terms of making sure that what comes out
as a prioritized item out of the um the
department is also then in balance with
what the people on the school building
Authority which are the State Fire
Marshal the Department of Education
itself uh a number of departments and
folks which are qualified to have a good
Financial backing background as well so
I I'm not so sure we should be dumping
something before we have really explored
it and discuss
that so uh those are several of the
concerns I have there other concerns
which I do have I do believe that we
have to recognize the disparities of
school districts in being able to cough
up the money for these and it's
necessary to maintain some process
whether it's 30 to 60 or the 20 to the
80 which are I believe in that bill
right now um that that's that's
important and I can support that um I
will I will stop my discussion right now
and just opening up for a a a more of a
discussion on this I'd like to hear from
rep luno his uh kind of perspective on
that Amendment and and uh and his angle
on some and answering some of the
questions I have um so could I could I
do that right now Mr
chair thanks and and I I have to
apologize um I also have a point of
personal privilege I have to be in house
finance to introduce a bill in four
minute in three minutes um so um uh I've
I emailed Mel at some uh a couple of
points on this but I'm just going to
highlight them very quickly I certainly
appreciate what uh what chairman lad has
been talking about on this the amendment
that I that I sent out this morning to
all members of the the committee just
basically lifts the uh the same um U
everything that's in in 214 which is
changing the um the recommended
appropriation from from no more than $50
million to no less than $50 million and
that that 50 million that appropriation
would also be inclusive of the uh tail
obligations so so it it lines up with
214 completely the uh the remaining
elements that are that are distinct to
594 that come out of the commission's
work and come out of numerous
discussions with director Clark are
moving away from 100% upfront to a
20-year plan um what that does is frees
up the um what what would be what would
be in a $50 million appropriation that
includes the tail would be in the first
year fy22 would be $15 million for
capital projects and um and $35 million
in tail obligations out of the 15
million in capital projects if it were
100% you'd only be able to do about um
15% of the projects with uh with House
Bill
594 um uh it's closer to 100% so you'd
be able to drill right down and address
that that backlog which I'm looking at
is is currently 270 million in projects
with a 104 u m dollar uh Grant award so
that's the first part the second part is
expanding the fiscal uh disparity R the
grant range to to align itself better
with with fiscal disparities around the
state um and then the third part is to
introduce projects in the moratorium um
and let them apply and they're limited
to a 20% Grant but uh anyway I I
apologize I have to jump and um and I'm
going to I'll certainly be monitoring
this so when a vote comes around um um
um am I
excused later all right thanks me Mel
can take any questions he was there all
right thanks let's just open this up to
the discussion right now where uh we can
have various
perspectives on on this bill Mr
chair yeah I I think just to to
reiterate what I was saying earlier uh
you know notwithstanding uh what the
chair said I mean this is a key issue
but I don't I think we need to put this
out there because we've got districts
that are that are in dire need of some
of this money I think representative
Luna's um bill here provides a way to
share the limited amount of funds that
we do have in a much fairer way than
what we've done in the
past and to and to delay it now is just
kicking the can down the road a little
bit more and and it seems to me that
some of the issues that chairman lad
mentioned can be dealt with uh we can
deal deal with that in the retain Bill
uh but I think we need to put forward
this issue uh to the finance committee
and really put it on their table to say
we need to deal with this we we've heard
this argument time and time again and I
think Now's the Time we need to move
this forward
thank you further
discussion
repres thank you I have a couple of
problems with with the bill one is the
multiple payments rather than what um
previous Bill had the problem why we are
here now because the legislature some
years ago said hey let's bond all these
payments and now we're stuck with you
why we don't have a building a problem
program we have a problem so I would
rather why I don't not this bill it
needs to be do what previous Bill had I
like that also 20 to
80 that's like hey you can if you prove
you're poor we'll build you a school no
that's not fair it's not fair to at 20%
nobody's going to be in a so-called Rich
District which they're not for example
my town is supposedly a rich town but
it's not longer live in the town both
parents have to work so that makes the
median household income High because
both parents
work but it's not a rich town it's a
properly poor town which is one part of
the bill I really like it goes
hopeing the adequacy aid formula where
you look at the property po but still 20
to 80 is no way I i' go with that and
also with the multiple payments over 20
years that's not going to prevent some
future legislator from doing the same
thing the legislator did some 10 years
ago
of longer than that
uh about hey let's just Bond all these
payments even though the treasurer said
no and everybody else said no and why
are we here now that's why I am against
the multiple payment thing so I'll put
that up thank you thank you very much uh
further
discussion we have any
answer represent
likeness yes I do like the um combining
the two into into the amendment where
saying that on the payments I like that
um I I have a lot of problems with the
multiple payments as well because it
actually puts a lot more cost onto the
local school district because of all
that interest that otherwise if you paid
up front the bond the school district
would have to take out would be much
smaller and therefore the interest paid
would be much smaller and by not paying
it up front but by paying it over time
and we're only paying on the principal
that means all that extra interest is
going to be put on the taxpayer and I
very much object to
that
um the other thing that I'm concerned
about is the whole idea of property rich
and property poor being the only
criteria that we have and you have towns
that are property
Poe but
um but that's just because of the way
their property is assessed versus
another town and and I think a much
better way to look at it is what is the
ability of the people in the town to pay
and we can't I know know what how much
they make but if we use the um free and
reduced lunch criteria that I think is a
much better picture of a Town's ability
to pay rather than what somebody
evaluated the property as and so I would
like to see this based on that
as long as we're you know coming up with
ideas okay uh I will trien right here um
the current law uses property
valuation and it uses medium family
income that's the old Cal capacity
disparity Aid formula which we've had
since since I know since I've been in
the house that's back to
2008 um so um
we we we if we're going to go with some
other way of doing it that would
definitely
necessitate a further study the the the
areas which specifically that I like
about this bill it has some changed time
or we need to look at the time schedule
in which uh intent and and applications
come in and moving forward and uh
towards final
approval uh I am uh concerned as to who
does approve and I need that clarified
so the only way that I will be able to
vote for something like this is if
there's changes made to the uh the bill
itself I'm also opposed to the multiple
payments uh the 80% UPF front was put in
place to try and reduce cost uh incurred
by the local town or municipality or or
or School District
and I believe that's worked the whole
process hasn't worked well simply
because we've never funded
it uh so those are my concerns right now
unless this thing is is going to be
amended further and we deal with it on
another day prior to the Pro or the day
that has to be out a committee I will
have to support uh a similar motion as
to what we gave
214 further discussion
I see any is any anybody there no I see
yes represent cordelli I was just
wondering if um from the people who have
objections if we could get a list of the
two or three items that um are
objectionable in the current
594 that could be possibly addressed in
an amendment um if someone so desires
what represented cordelius just said is
that if we could identify some of those
questions folks have and we we brought
some of those out the multiple payments
80% up front etc etc uh if we could
address some of those things and keep
the good stuff and move this thing along
and also because we have retained to
more we have the opportunity to really
get into a discussion but we also from a
policy perspective convey Our concern
that School building 8 needs to be
looked at and we need to start funding
it we have too many old buildings
remember the figures we have 50% of our
buildings they're well over 60 years old
some have been renovated but we do know
that there's a lot of issues within
those older buildings that need support
so uh F the comments and then we're
going to have to take some one way the
other on
this
rep rep like yeah I have a question
about what you
just so what will we do just not p on
this bill today and put come up with an
amendment and then come back like the
next like Tuesday and um look at the
amendment or I mean what what is the
process your that would be the only
process which would be available is that
that those that have those those
questions I receive those questions then
I'd be glad to work with the the prime
sponsor of this bill and and the work to
try you know there'd have to be
compromises and uh but we'd have
something move forward and it be more
than 214 was alone uh if we can't get
there then we would have to go for
forward uh when we meet again the next
week we would probably see a motion for
retention
and there after we saw a 214 there's
probably a strong possibility we see
retention so the best option I see here
as far as the try and and present an
amendment to 594 uh reflecting those
concerns that have been spoken
to represent
Miler are you suggesting then uh Mr
chair that we set this aside until next
week yes so there'll be no motion at
this point in time on this bill that's
why I started the discussion in
right yeah but it would be put aside to
be exact next
week certainly have to work with others
to try and figure out okay uh can we can
we get this thing done I think we
can but uh I hope we can because all the
stuff that I read during the hearing
regarding how this affects achievement
and health of students is important and
we shouldn't we from a poliy perspective
we need to recognize
I would I would support just setting
this aside till next week and work on it
in the meantime okay as the ranking uh
representative on the other side and
you're hearing the chair right here
agreed we are not going to be further
executing this bill
today okay folks uh that moves us on um
I know down this end a few people have
been taking bathroom breaks uh I'd like
to see uh us take a five 10 minute you
know
I this year are break to to allow some
of the body functions to
work is there objection that okay we'll
take 10 minutes for everybody you guys
at home go hit the
refrigerator representative lad I'm
going to go ahead and mute the room for
you guys just remember to unmute before
you begin after your break thank you
very
much
e
for
you
I got the draft off and I still I'm
going to be work I've got this 11 to 113
it really it's it is an IT
process for
me
shot in Hawai oh there you
go years
ago are we unmuted right nowed one of
these okay
great pi
what time are we supposed to come
back and didn't look I thought about
yeah it's been at least five minutes you
said five minutes no I said 10 minutes
oh I'm sorry I thought
five usually not but today it's cold in
here
I
have I's in a hurry I put mine all
together and with my glasses on I can't
read the little things and it was
actually open rather than closed and I
stopped suddenly in the car and ended up
with the most of my liquid all over my
seat and and
everything your amendment I would for a
couple okay I we're back can everybody
hear
me no there are several people that are
still not other I know that's I'm
trying Oliver can you hear me out
there yeah okay he hears me good okay so
we're
coming okay I'm going to call this
executive session back to order
here um I don't see it uh how many do we
have
here well looks like we have most
everybody back and
only okay
're we're going to go ahead and the
we're going to go up to the top back to
the top and we're going to be dealing
with HB
194 uh this is a bill to release uh
deals with the release of student
assessment information and
data we had two similar bills that were
looked at on that particular day at the
particular time the other was HB
323 um one dealt with the
Department um working with the uh
testing agency to release the
information that way and the other was
was uh with the specific date of June 30
with that that was 323 we're starting
with 194 first and I'd like to
recognize uh representative uh cordelli
thank you Mr chair um I would like to U
move on to pass with uh
Amendment 02
688 that hopefully everyone has um it
was mailed out last night and there
printed copies here uh this
morning does everybody out there have a
copy of that
Amendment uh those there remote wise I'm
speaking to I see folks walking around
here picking up a copy
yeah I I don't see anybody with their
hand up out
top
represent Cornell you have a copy yes
I'm not hearing you represent Cornell is
that oh that's
because okay great thank you I have a
copy okay um so we have a motion on the
floor to pass with
Amendment uh once again cordelli that
was uh
2688 yeah
cordelli has made that motion second by
represent
L represent cordelli could you please
explain yes or discuss your amended
Amendment please we're dealing with the
amendment uh thank you very much Mr
chairman
um this is a pretty simple um current
law provides um as you see in 193
C12 Roman 2 the department um uh may
send out assessment results uh to
parents uh the issue has been and need
for this legislation uh is because there
are um a few districts who are not
sending out this information in a timely
fashion which uh actually um violates uh
federal law and uh could jeopardize um
Federal payments uh to those
districts so in this uh Amendment I've
simply added the ability uh for the
testing entity itself uh to provide uh
the uh assessment information and uh
related data uh to uh the families um
relieving uh districts of that uh I
added enrollment three uh language from
uh the other Bill
323 uh that is also consistent with a
federal law that the report that is
provided to parents uh should be in a um
informative manner uh easily
understandable by the parents uh so that
they can uh help uh their children um
with the standards and uh uh learning uh
that would go along based on the
assessment results
um so that's really all there is to the
uh Amendment which basically replaces
the
Bill thank thank you very much re
cordelli Reon Leon you second that
motion do you have any discussion to add
I don't have anything to add thank you
Mr chair representative M did you have a
question thank you Mr chair uh so
representative cordelli this uh takes
out the uh class B felony issue wording
um thank you for the question um
actually I I went back and double
checked and that is already in statute
um if the uh if there is a uh release of
that confidential information by anyone
uh intentionally in the department um
but that is current law thank
you further discussion representative
elas yeah um just to follow up on
representative moffets
um representative cordelli you said um
that's already if the department
releases it is there anything in there
that talks about if the testing entity
releases
it I I believe uh I believe that there
is the um uh existing statute um
restricts the T testing agency into uh
the fact that they can only release
information um in relation to uh
validating uh someone's uh taking of the
test that's the only allowable use of
that confidential data thank you thank
you very much further questions we have
re Miler and re Cornell represent Miler
uh thank you Mr chairman again we we
we've dealt with this before and we have
asked
[Music]
the you're coming give us the names or
the numbers of districts that this is
addressing in can you hear me okay yes
now we
can not you're not coming can you hear
me yeah hear you can hear me okay now
yeah yes can you hear me
yes can you hear us so I you're not not
not being able to hear me
okay yes yeah I can hear you can you
hear
me you you can't
hear okay
okay so so we we we've dealt with this
last time and time before we asked
theart to give us
information should TR
yeah should turn his video off do you
have your video on he
does I would
Su can how about it represent Myer
now he's muted here okay can you hear me
now yes yes yes okay all right the
Dilemma that we had here is that we have
asked the Department of Education on
several occasions to give us a a list a
number of the of school districts that
are not
complying you know and we don't get that
we just hear oh they're not sending them
out without any
specifics and so that's one concern I
guess that we have with this the other
concern is
confidentiality we have spent a lot of
time in this um in this committee to
ensure that student information parent
information Etc is
confidential this is opening that wide o
wide open and thirdly we've heard from
school districts that say how they use
the report of this
information and they use this from a
diagnostic standpoint so that they can
meet with parents they can talk with
parents about the meaning of the results
for their for their students for their
children and this would abgate that by
by having a massive send out from a
central
location so I think this is a
misuse of the problem when there is no
problem or at least we have not been
told the specifics of the problem so I
would hardly uh encourage the committee
not to pass this because I don't think
it's necessary and it again jeopardizes
the relationship that a local school
district has with parents
as relating to diagnostic work etc and
finally we also heard that in some
school districts they don't get this
information until late in the school
year anyway and so the dec the January
the June 30th date is a problem thank
you further further discussion from the
committee rep Cornell rep representative
Cornell um R Miler said much of what I
was going to say but I also wanted to
add that this adds much more work for
the Department um to to do when they're
already overburdened and don't have
enough time to do the things that we've
already asked them uh to do and I was
wondering should there be a fiscal note
with this because if it's going to be
mailed out from the Department to every
student's family who's taken the test
that would be a lot of money wouldn't it
and I I may have missed that but it
seems like that that would be quite a
bit of money and would require a fiscal
note in addition to adding more work for
the poor Department that we asked to do
a lot of other things uh represent
Corell I'm gonna ask representative uh
cordelli to respond it's my
understanding that this is mailed out uh
by the testing agency not the department
and the testing agencies have offered
they they do this in many many states at
no extra cost they just want our
business so that's something that's been
afforded to us but we haven't been able
to do it because of our statutory
language representative cordelli thank
you um the
existing statute 193 C12 says that the
department May provide the assessment
results and data to the parent which I
think goes to your point representative
Cornell about the expense for the
department but that is the existing
statute this adds the option for the
testing entity um to uh provide that
information at no additional burden to
the department or cost uh to the
state follow up yes so we'd be releasing
every student who's taken the test
address um and information to the
testing entity and what happens if they
go to me the they take the test and the
student moves soon after taking the test
how will they even know that Celli thank
you um several things I believe that an
existing statute now based on
legislation that was passed in the last
term uh some of that assessment data is
maintained by the department u in the uh
student uh data system so the department
will have that information if student
moves or anything uh
likewise we have further questions three
hands uh ref Andrews and then Mullen and
then
my repr Andre Thank you Mr chair I'm in
favor of this bill because for me the
bottom line is the information on these
assessment tests belong to the parents
and what they do with that information
is their business and if the their child
needs help and the school doesn't have
time to go through the test Rhythm I
think we need to give parents more
leeway and let them know what's going on
with their child thank you thank you
very much further further discussion re
Mullen re Mullen thank you Mr chair um
and thank you representative cordelli
it's actually a question for you um in
section two of the amendment it says uh
at Roman numeral 2 line 10 the
department May provide or may request
the testing entity to provide the
assessments to
parents guardians or uh the pupil school
so that's a May and then in section
three it talks about the report shall be
provided to the parents I don't see any
provision for the school getting the
report uh I I see a May request May
provide but I don't see a shall provide
to the school uh is that stated
somewhere else in 193 that I have uh yet
to
unearth I I believe it is but I I would
also read it um the current statute says
the department May provide
um to the parents guarding or pupil
school as provided in 193
C11 um so my my uh my issue
representative cordelli is that prior to
this change the schools were receiving
the reports and sending the reports out
so we know that the school was getting
the report because the school was
responsible for sending the report um I
just don't see any provision for that
school getting those reports for the
school file um because obviously this
information is going to be pretty
critical to them as
well go ahead yes yes is my
understanding that the school um
automatically gets that information
almost immediately after that the uh
test uh um is
taken so I don't think that there's any
problem with the school not getting the
data okay I guess we'll we'll have to
wait and see should this uh should this
go through thank you we we had testimony
from the Department during the hearing
of this bill that the school does
receive this instantly uh from from the
you know due to the technology that's
associated with this test right my point
my point Mr sh is that as the law
currently exists the school is tasked
with providing the information to the
parent therefore it receives the results
as part of that process if we take the
school out of the process of providing
the information to the parent my
question then is do we need to stipulate
that the school shall receive or have
access to the results it's uh it
certainly I I understand your response
uh yeah to follow up with that uh under
Essa and you look at the Assurance this
portion of it which is uh associated
with the section 1111 four ones
parentheses B parentheses 3 it says in
general each local Education Agency plan
shall provide assurances that the local
Education Agency will inure and ensure
that the results from the academic
assessments required under Section it
lists again that code M will be provided
to parents and teachers as soon as is
practicably possible after the test is
taken in an understandable in uniform
format and to the extent practicable
provided in the language that the
parents can understand so Federal Law
requires the LA to to do that basically
as soon as possible again I just want to
state that we're changing the law if we
it if we supersede the school district
receiving the information in order to
send it to the parent then uh none of
that is going to be applicable because
the school will no longer be
responsible for sending it to the parent
so I just want to acknowledge the idea
that we are changing the order of
operations here if you will on who gets
the information when and how it gets to
parents thank you very much uh are there
F Is there further discussion yeah we
had R Miler then wood
then okay representative Myer then
represent Woodcock and then represent L
thank you thank you Mr chair this is for
representative cordelli that in a in the
conversation that we had earlier in the
testimony was there any clarification of
how soon the testing agency may have a
portal with which the parent can go in
and get that
information I I do not recall a time
frame associated with that other than it
was in the works I believe but I stand
to be corrected on any time frames that
were mentioned all right I I just raised
that because if in fact there there
would be a portal for parents to get
that information that would also provide
more immediate access to that dat to
thank you representative
whitcock thank you Mr chairman I I have
a question on the amendment for uh
representative cordelli if it's possible
I have two questions actually uh
representative cordelli I'm looking at
section three where it said the report
shall be provided the part that I'm that
I want Clarity on where it says
informative and instructional Mana to
help the children meet the challenging
State ecademic Standards yet what does
that actually mean
um I think that that uh language is
taken from the uh other bill that
addressed this issue
323 um and was reflected in the uh Essa
uh standards that the uh chairman uh
just read as
well well follow up Mr chairman yes
thank you that doesn't answer the
question but that's okay what is if it's
going to be a report let me go to PO B
then what is that what does that mean
and as it looks like to the Stu where it
says the report if it's coming directly
from the testing agency how how is this
going to be indivi individualized for
students and parents to get the
information they
need that's a question the report either
from the school district the department
or the testing agency uh shall be
provided in an informative uh and
understandable manner to the parents um
uh I'm not sure if you're looking for a
layout of the report or uh I'm not sure
U what you're looking for in that regard
followup Mr
chairman go ahead that's that's the
exact you're giving me the answer to the
exact same question I just asked you
which was what is form instructional you
g that now use as an answer a minute ago
was a question my point is if I receive
a document from the taston agency about
youngsta that says they need these these
uh additional Services because their
grades are low their assessment levels
are low how is that going to be
personalized so the parents know what
they're getting so they can do something
about it who does that if it comes from
the N does the agency do that who does
that I believe that the report that is
sent out now I I would ask then U how
does the school personalize that data um
we've heard testimony that that some
schools wait uh until the fall to go
over those results at the beginning of
the school year um which I think is uh
one of the concerns about the federal
requirements under Essa in terms of a
timely uh information to the parent
um I I I I'm not sure if I understand
really what the problem is in this
regard Sor final final followup Mr
chairman so the the point is represent
qu
that the report that you're talking
about that you in the amendment that
came today at least me today on im3
talks about providing providing uh
access providing information and I'm
asking you who does it don't kick it
back to the school does it supposedly in
September we fall we're talking about
this report in your Amendment that's all
it's like send our report so we can get
it out there but you're leaving the
parent hanging and it says you're going
to provide something I'm asking you who
provides it well how they how they
personalize it that's all thank you Mr
chairman
um the current statute
reads 193
C12 uh in part the department May
provide the assessment results and
comparative data to the parent legal
guardian or pupil pupil school as
provided in the uh P Tire
paragraph um basically we're adding that
the option that the testing entity do
the same thing and requiring that it be
in an informative format that uh is
understandable to the
parent okay go ahead just it's
clarifying the um existing statute and
that it has to be informative uh to the
parent um which reflects the Esser
requirement represent
and
then
represent oh
um I had two things but well I had one
but I just wanted to go back to what the
testimony they gave was my understanding
was that the format that the testing
agency put all these out
into was that informative
whatever type so it would be the testing
agency I mean this is my understanding
from the hearing and what they said is
it's the testing agency that puts that
out whether they put it to the
department or the school or the kid that
they're the one that puts it in that
informative um
format and the other thing I is
um doesn't Essa take
um precedent I take um don't we have to
follow the Essa
regulations regardless of this bill so
the fact that the Essa regulations say
that
um I'm sorry I've lost it I was trying
to respond to representative Mullen and
say that we may be changing the state
part of this but the federal part has to
remain the same I
believe further
questions Tanner is rep Tanner thank you
Mr chair um I would like to go back to
the portal issue I was wondering if
there's somebody online that's from the
State Department of Education who might
be able to let us know the status of the
parent portal on the
tests represent we're not we're not able
to hear you
you're you're coming in very
quietly okay that helps I bet um that's
better um I'm wondering if there's
somebody from the doe that's in the
audience who might be able to give us
some information about the parent portal
because it seems if the portal is there
uh then this bill is
unnecessary thank
you I don't see anyone with their hand
rais um yeah I'm looking down through
those that are attendees and seeing uh
if there's somebody there she raised her
hand Diana F yes attorney Fenton is
there so we'll open up uh her ability to
participate go ahead Miss
Benton thank you members of the
committee let me see if I can get
Melissa white to answer that question I
myself do not know but let me um track
her down for you
okay bear with me for a minute thank
you
allow to talk do you want me toote her
so we can
see
what floor is Diana floor one and she
has go to floor
four she's not in the middle of
L
are there any further any further
discussion before Diana comes
back no okay we'll just hang loose
here
to
space in
here
is Miss Fenton are you
there I
am I am available um I have put out the
word to three of my colleagues and no
one's responded to me
it's just one of those days but um we
can get you that information and get
back to you as soon as I
can well we're in executive session
right now
so oh I will continue to Rattle their
cages okay bring litigation against if
they don't show
up okay thank you very much
Diana I have a followup Mr
chair may I have a
followup yes uh Mr chair could we um
retain this bill or uh table it I don't
know if that's possible until we get
this
information well we do have a motion on
the floor right now and it's been second
so we have to act upon the
motion we have
a a question okay rip
sha
um to I'm I'm not sure maybe I'm not
reading it right but it seems to me that
the amendment takes a is more definitive
on the fact that the testing entity
provides the information whereas the
original Bill uh has the May request so
it it all
uh some
flexibility on whether the districts
decide to let the entity provide the
information or whether the district
would prefer to do it their way with
their conferences or whatever it is that
they uh um that they use to distribute
the
results um I personally like the
approach that many district views where
they have uh the conferences the last
quarter and they use they they give the
test results to the parents and they
explain what they mean because uh I do
not feel that a uh a testing entity is
going to have the language in it that
reaches uh all of the parents especially
those who are either non-english
speaking or whatever um I think it would
be easier to not have the amendment to
just leave it I like the the June 30th
date and and uh it was stated in
testimony that the information comes up
almost immediately when the child is
done with the test so it could be
disseminated at that time so I think the
bill itself is is good and I I will
support the bill but I'm questioning
whether the amendment puts a little more
emphasis on the testing entity that I
prefer to leave as May
request that's just my opinion thank you
very much
representative representative Shaw for
as a as a point for you to consider is
that the testing date of of June 30th is
not in this bill that's in three
23 oh sorry that's that's another bill
this is a bill simply that allows the
testing entity to send materials off
to representative leus you have your
hand up uh yes thank you Mr chair
representative Lon my mother just
retired from teaching third grade and a
98% free and reduced lunch highly
immigrant mostly English Lang language
learner school and the testing
organizations were able to provide those
results to the parents in Spanish taglog
and and um some other other rare
dialects that were coming from South
America as well so I'm not sure about
who we contract with but I know that
there's actually some great
opportunities for them to communicate
those school scores perhaps even better
than the teacher for some of these elll
students thank you very much is there
further
discussion we have um Melissa white I
still have Diana Fenton in the group and
representative Cornell so I'm not sure
who you'd like to take first
uh uh representative uh excuse me
attorney Fenton are you
there okay I'm available and I
understand that Melissa white is on
available to answer your questions as
they pertain to assessments okay so you
would defer to miss white yes she's the
subject matter expert in this area thank
you very much uh rips and Hopson can put
white
on go ahead this is Melissa white I am
the assessment administrator at the New
Hampshire Department of Education and
I'm available to answer any
questions he represent Cordell could you
add sort of summarize the questions
which we have yes thank you Mr chairman
uh I think uh that the basic question
was about the uh portal Parent Portal
that was mentioned uh during the hearing
um and the status of that uh uh
tool okay yes I um did speak with our
camem assessment uh vendor on Friday and
they are going to be looking into that
they were working on De Dev developing
that Parent Portal last year and then
once um we had the pandemic hit they
switched to developing and putting all
their resources into developing remote
administration of the assessments so
that project was put on hold I think
their plan is to pick that back up again
um this summer but they were going to
provide me a a
timeline um next week so hopefully
they'll be able to get that to me and
then I can share that with you so the
parent portal is not available at this
time but it is in
development thank you very much are
there questions for Miss White from
committee members we have re Cornell and
uh White
representative Cornell Thank you for
taking the time to come over and answer
our questions I was just wondering if
you had the information of how many
school districts don't Supply this
information to parents in a timely
matter how many don't send them home you
know or in time CF meetings or put them
off I'm not sure the exact number of
schools that are not providing this
information usually at the department we
tend to hear from the parents that did
not receive it and so they reach out to
us about that I'm I'm sorry there's some
feedback there um so what we don't have
exact numbers of how many schools are
not doing that we just tend to hear from
U parents that reach out to us and then
we reach out to the school to please uh
release that information to parents H
about how many parents reach out to you
to go I would imagine the parents that
reach out are from the same
schools you have any idea of how
many not necessarily sometimes it's
districtwide uh I can only really
because I have only been in this
position for about a year and we did not
have an Administration last spring I can
speak to the um fall Administration and
I would say I've had about 25 parents
reach out to me about just Statewide
about wanting to receive their results
okay thank you and I apologize I I
didn't mention with the SAT T that
Parent Portal is available so parents do
have access to the SAT portal to get
their students results and so do the
students so that is in um effect right
now and they can access that so I'm
sorry I didn't clarify that
earlier Miss Miss White do you have time
for one more question yes sir
absolutely like this question yes I do
have a question for you um I understand
that in law at the moment it says that
the testing agency can't give out any of
the information that we give them my
question is is there any is there any
teeth behind that what happens if they
do so and let me see if I understand the
question correctly do we have the
ability to give the assessment results
to
parents no the testing res the testing
entity gets information on the students
and they're not allowed to give that out
to anybody except you know who we say
that they can give it out to and my
question is if they were to give it out
you know for security reasons I'm
wondering if they were to give it out to
somebody else do we have any
um anything that we can do you know just
I believe in um I would have to go back
and look at our contract but I believe
our memor our memorandum of
understanding or our exchange agreement
um because it is a doit Overlook
contract there's very specific um
guidelines around who can be who that
information can be shared with it's
pretty explicit so but I'd have to go
back and look at the contract more
closely to see um who we've
designated so if they gave it to
somebody else um be they would be
violating a contract and we could go
after them um for a violation of the
contract is that true I believe so but I
would probably prefer to have an
attorney answer that question if that's
okay yeah you're right thank you
sorry okay F further questions uh we
have reer and
uh misson would like to
speak okay repr Miler okay so so we now
have uh I mean there's no question that
parents need to have these reports I
mean there's no debate around that the
question is the timing of it
and we just heard from the Department
that there's been 25 parents who have
called in we're not sure whether those
25 are from one one school or one school
district we're talking about 25 parents
out of
165,000
students who participate in testing in
this
state this bill is not
needed these the obviously if these
parents parents have a problem these 25
they need to talk with the local school
district we're talking about changing a
policy that obviously is working in 99%
of the situation here why would we want
to change this if that is the practice
that is working at this point in time
according to Miss White from the
Department of Education it's just not
needed
here we do she she lowered her hand she
lowered her
hand oh I'm still on though I I think it
just lowered me but yes I'm still
here I thought yeah somebody said that
di hand was back up so she has further
comments she can speak if she wants to
Miss V do you have any additional
information just briefly and thank you
uh members of the committee um in
regards to the prior question it would
be a breach of contract um and it would
allow presumably the department to sue
the company and it would also give us
reasons to exit that contract and
presumably seek another vendor um from a
business standpoint that's reason enough
for the private company to make sure
that they don't violate that um but that
would enable the department to seek that
remedy of of suing
them we have not had that situation
occur so I can't speak to any particular
case in which we've been successful in
that but in theory that's what would
occur thank you very much with that I'm
G try to move into uh taking action on
the
amendment rep Tanner this will be the
last uh person recognized for a
discussion thank you thank you Mr chair
I would just like to ask uh Miss White
uh with those 25 parents how was that
resolved the uh
issue um so I did send out a notice to
the building administrator and then to
the superintendent's office um just um
requesting that they please provide the
parent with the information and the
results and then also um offered support
on how to access those results in case
they were not sure how to find that
information to be able to provide it to
the parents um and a followup um just uh
were the parents satisfied with that
um at this time I think
so thank you thank you very much so with
that we're going to move in the motion
to and the motion is uh to move towards
octop pass with the amendment and the
amendment number was
H and so we're voting on the amendment
we're voting on the amendment then the
motion is ought to pass with that
Amendment not on the bill but on the
amendment represent Port Ali yeah
representative B yes representative
Allard yes representative Le yes
representative M yes representative
Hobson yes representative and yes
representa
Ford that
for he's muted oh there he is
yeah you're
muted there we go yes thank you
representative Leon yes representative s
yes representative
miler
no l
no no represent Cornell
no Tanner no Ellison no mull
no le no wood
no
vad
yes
119 representative lad representative
Cornell will issue the uh Minority
Report that was just on the amendment
yeah oh excuse me on the amendment okay
another I recognize represent cordelli
for a motion thank you Mr chairman I
would like to move to pass as amended on
House Bill 194
and
represent and it's second by represent
LE uh further
discussion not seeing any uh Madam clerk
we have a motion to approve the uh 194
as
amended representative cordelli yes
representative B yes representative Gard
yes representative
leus
really not liking the giving the
information out
um
yes yes representative Hobson yes
representative and yes representative
Ford yes representative Leon yes
representative s yes represent
Miler
noo no repr no repres Cornell no Tanner
no Ellison no Mullen
no no
Woodcock you're muted
Steve thank you
no represent lad
yes
119 okay uh 194 passes as amended uh is
there a minority yeah representative
Cornell will give the Minority Report Mr
chair thank you very
much and represent cordelli you'll be
doing
the majority report thank you very much
uh we have time for one more bill this
morning we're going to go to HB
242 thank you Mr chman um I would like
to
open executive session on health Bill
242 relative to the content of an
adequate education we call on the prime
sponsor uh representative
L I'd like to uh move uh 242 on to pass
with Amendment
H thank you very much do I have a second
on that motion second
representative hon second that um would
the uh make motion like to speak to his
motion yes uh I'll speak uh briefly to
the amendment which is 0262 H uh the
amendment has three
components uh within it the first one uh
places four
definitions into the statute that as
request of what we heard at the hearing
rigorous academic study means a course
program or grade level program aligned
with curriculum standards and school
approval standards applied learning
means an educational approach whereby
students have the opportunity to
directly engage in learning activities
using Knowledge and Skills theories and
models that may be outside of the
traditional classroom experience or
embedded as part of a course program or
grade level
program logic means a reasoning skill
that better enables a student to analyze
problems in core knowledge domains such
as mathematics and to develop problem
solutions to better understand the
principle of cost and effect and to
develop critical thinking skills to
better identify fact from unverified
information or
data rhetoric means the skill of
speaking and writing as a means of
communication or
persuasion the second part of the
amendment deals with the fiscal capacity
disparity components of of uh
the content for an adequate education it
speaks to the equalized valuation per
pupil and it also addresses the uh
achievement levels of uh students in
level one and level two the non
proficiency areas on the Statewide
assessment that may be uh in school
districts which are above or even in
that uh equiz that property valuation
per pupil and lastly uh in respect to
some of what we heard at the hearing
there was one sentence there before in
the bill which required the on the
accountability
side
that the
department would be uh administering a
our our apartment shall Implement
corrective and technical assistance in
accordance with RSC 193 e3e that has
been taken out of this bill the part
that remains in accountability is the
responsibility of the schools to put
this on their website and to communicate
the fact that their school has a problem
in this input or narrative type uh
process for reporting uh where you are
in the school or School District this is
the sum total of the the amendment the
amendment uh is repl adds to the primary
Bill 242 and the amending languages in
response to some of the hearing
information we heard the other day thank
you thank
youson I have nothing to add thank you
um comments questions from the uh
members on the
amendment see any don't see any um oh
excuse me represent MAF thank you thank
you uh represent just two quick comments
uh when we had the hearing on this I I
listened to folks who testified
particularly Dr Carl lad uh everybody
but
uh particularly him when he speaks for
the uh school superintendent Association
and and he was neutral on this um which
was telling uh did not oppose it and he
also flagged and some other folks
flagged some issues that I thought were
good issues or or good uh points that
needed to be addressed and this
amendment I think does that uh as the
chair just explained so uh I think this
is a good Amendment IT addresses the
issues that came up at hearing and uh I
hope it moves
forward thank you um any other comments
questions concerning the
amendment seeing
none okay Madam KK would you take a roll
call on the
amendment
this is on
Amendment
H and the motion is a to
pass representative lad yes
representative bone yes representative
Allard yes representative lakas yes
representative Mett yes representative
Hobson yes representative Andress yeses
Ford yes representative Leon yes
representative s
yes Miler
noid luno
no representative Char yes
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Ellison no
representative Mullen no representative
life
no
wood no repr cordelli
yes
12 very
much back to the uh main motion which
will be ought to pass as
amended
do I'll have someone to make that
motion yes uh thank you represent Val
I'll move oop pass as amended for House
Bill
242 M Mr
chair yes point of order um I'd like to
offer um and and and add my hand up
before you um made that but but uh on
the floor the bill um has been amended
and is open for further Amendment and I
move to offer amendment number
2021 uh- 0251 h
I believe I had already uh called to the
motion the V pass is amended and
representative lad
U indicated uh making that motion and it
was seconded by repres options right and
the and the bill was open to further
Amendment and I had my hand
up this is an ought to pass motion so it
was was was open for further open to
further
amendment I I was looking at you is
there paperwork
or was emailed this
morning look at it this morning has
anyone seen that at 8:56
a.m.
um we we talked um with the researcher
this morning um about uh amendments and
um it was indicated that if we send our
amendments that we get from uh OS to
house committee Services HCS um they
will print copies for people in U in
attendance as well as uh emailing them
out to people um so that you know
hopefully we can get them a little bit
earlier than uh the start of the uh uh
meeting it's a simple small Amendment
it's
a was that communicated to to the
committee wasn't Comm communicated to
me you want to
try no I didn't no I didn't see and I
and I looked before I focus my attention
on you yeah um I don't know I I did not
see um a hand up um when we we can
review the we can review the
video back I think what you do is just
order support is to recess this for
about five minutes call the clerk and
get some definition yeah okay all right
we'll uh we'll check in with the clerk
and we'll uh go into recess for a few
minutes fair
enough
just um let's see if uh CL is
listening I
have yeah I got
it did you see what the elment was I
haven't seen it oh I just looked it up
it's it's putting the bu into
it right here
go
so
right
e
see the corner of everyone out there can
you hear us now
yeah thank thank you for your patience
um we have uh discussed the amendment
situation uh with both the house Clerk
and the speaker and uh it has been ruled
that this amendment is non gerine and
therefore inappropriate at this time so
we will proceed with i' like to
challenge challenge the ruling of the
chair second that the U the speaker has
ruled that is non gerain I am
challenging the speaker's ruling okay
well you you can take that up with the
speaker right no no this is in the this
is a committee issue that we're dealing
with right
now this bill clearly is in the purview
of this particular bill before us for
exact session thank you we'll proceed
with the uh ought to passes amended with
I like to I like to uh I want to pose a
formal objection to this I want it in
the record that this is inappropriate at
this point in time not to do this with
the ruling of the chair so not so yeah
thank you very
much Al oh well I just as far as Germain
or not Germain it say that's that's a
settled issue from the speaker that's
fine so we will proceed with the ought
to pass this amended motion um with uh
Amendment
0262 uh question representative
Celli yes just procedurally as as a
relatively new person I never I never
heard the Speaker of the House making a
ruling on a committee uh action you tell
me if that's happened before I'm just
trying to
learn the uh speaker uh always rules on
germanness of amendments if there's a
question and that is what he has
done so that's been done before this
last year I missed it I guess not in
this
committee
in the house the uh speaker rules on
whether bills are gerain or not when
there is a question as to that fact so
we will proceed with the vote and um
it's just hard to it's just hard to
believe given the fact that they both
amend the same section of the statute
E2 there was certainly um uh the need
for a public hearing on uh the amendment
um there was no uh fiscal note for the
bill and this amendment provided that so
I will call on the um clerk to call the
role on the o passes amended
motion point of
order yes is you just used the fiscal
Noe as a as a re as a rationale to to
call it non gerain is there a fiscal
note on the um on the amendment that's
being voted on now that was my comment
the uh house Speaker just plainly stated
that it was not in
Germain well you're the chair and you
used you just used the fiscal note as a
rationale that was my time um clerk are
you waiting for the RO Mr Mr chair I
also object the fact that we weren't
privy to the discussion with the speaker
and with the clerk uh we had absolutely
no input nor did we hear any of this
discussion and that seems like as
representatives and this affects all of
us that that would be something that
would be
important cler are you ready yes thank
you vad
yes represent yes
representative yes representative lak
yes representative Mett
yes hson
yes andas yes
for you're
muted
yes
represent yes represent yes represent
Miler
noo absolutely
no representative sha no representative
Cornell no representa Tanner I object to
the procedure and no on the
bill Ellison
no Mullen
no le no repr Woodcock I also object to
the procedure and vote no on this
craziness
yes
represent there be a Minority Report yes
representative luno will issue that
report thank you very much and no no
please note my objection to the
procedure as
well in the
record
um I think uh I'll turn it back over to
the chair at this point okay what we're
going to do now is move forward and we
have uh
a bill which is going to start at 1:30
this afternoon so we still have some
time here to exact uh other bills which
we have on the docket thought you said
earlier we're taking a break or this is
the last
one we do one more bill here
um looking at uh HB
349 school nurse program and
certification check with the speaker
make sure it's okay
okay this is a bill that removes the
requirement for School nurses to be
certified by the State Board of
Education uh represent B you're
recognized for a motion thank you Mr
chair and I make a most of all to
pass repres M I'd like to second that so
we have a motion made off to pass by
representative B and second by
representative mofet uh discussion from
the prime spons or the the uh maker of
the
motion yes just briefly
um we've heard testimony that and I know
personally there is a short of good
nurses and let's and and schools are
actually changing the definition so they
can hire different people uh and even
Public Public Health nurses so the thing
is let's let the district and the doe
make the criteria for what they want for
their particular
requirement the thing is we had a lot of
discussion on nurses with an as degree
or one with a BS
degree you don't become a nurse from
degrees you come become a Nerf nurse by
taking a national test the
nclex-rn test when you leave College
either with a two-year degree or a BS
degree you're an either ASN or BSN it's
not an RN you have to take this
nationalized
test
so and every whether not your associate
degree or a bachelor's degree you still
have to take the same test as the hard
test was I know personally for my
granddaughter have do but the thing is
let's let the school districts and the
doe make the determination the criteria
they want oh by the way not anybody can
take this test you have to have
graduated from a nursing
college thank you thank you representa m
thank you m uh briefly since we had a
hearing on this bill uh there's been
considerable commentary uh via various
media
platforms uh and also emails and
messages and calls uh that we've all
received on behalf of
nurses uh in the value and compet the
value and competency of nurses who
products of associate degree programs I
actually used to work at NTI and and saw
firsthand uh what what these uh Nur
nurses did in an associate program uh Dr
Susan you
who leads the uh Community col system of
New Hampshire eloquently maybe some of
you saw her long
bed uh ELO eloquently making the case
that all nurses as representative bum
just said need to pass the same lure
exam so uh I join all those who support
the notion that licensed registered
nurses are
qualified to be School nurses thank you
thank you very much have hands raised oh
okay rep Miler and rep Tanner representa
Miler thank you Mr chair uh first of all
just just for the record according to
the uh testimony that was given during
our hearing there is no shortage there
are only two vacancies currently in
School nurses as we sit today so there's
not there's not a shortage at this point
in time the other point I would like to
make is that um obviously we recognize
the value of these First Responders both
in schools and outside of schools and
that's very important for us the Dilemma
that we have here is that again for the
for those of you that are new to the
committee uh this credentialing process
that is currently in the law was one
that has been developed over the years
it did not come about uh uh overnight
this was a long fought battle on the
part of the current School nurses to
have this credential
in the law and
to defeat this to remove this would be a
non-recognition of the of the value of
those nurses who have been F whove been
fighting to get this credential in the
law and I really would encourage you not
to support this motion thank you thank
you very much representative Miler uh
who's next in the C
uhan Tanner Tanner thank you Mr chair
can you hear me all right now yeah thank
you um I think it's a sad day uh when we
are ignoring the needs of those parents
and their children who have complex
medical issues have food insecurity
homelessness mental and emotional issues
or face life-threatening emergency
situations in the isolation of a public
school without a certified school nurse
parents want their children to get
urgent care and be safe they want their
children regardless of special needs to
be able to attend our public school with
their
peers this bill is about repealing the
requirement for specific knowledge and
experience that the New Hampshire Nurses
Association and the New Hampshire school
Nurses
Association strongly believe are
necessary to provide consistent
competent and quality care for our
school children and for the safety
health and well-being of the students
their parents the teachers the staff and
the communities at our Public Schools
the real message here is that parents of
school children want the best medical
care and safety for their child during
the many hours they spend at school for
the safety and well-being of our school
children I will vote no for the third
time on this bill to take away the
certification for School nurses thank
you thank you further discussion
anybody there I
don't okay not seeing any we'll go ahead
has his hand up repr okay thank you
thank you Mr chair uh I just wantan to I
just want to Echo what representative
Tanner has said I mean I'm new to the
committee so I don't understand all of
the perhaps all of the nuances of the
issue
particularly of uh all the past
iterations but it does seem to me there
has to be a significant and substant
some sort of substantive difference
between a BSN and the associates I
understand that in both cases they take
the same test in order to become a
registered
nurse but I think that uh the goal and
the the the responsibilities of the
school nurse are obviously those of an
RN but they also Encompass many broader
issues particularly public health issues
uh food issues mental and emotional
health and well-being and these are the
kinds of issues that are dealt with
through the BSN uh program as opposed to
the associates which tends to focus more
on the immediate and clinical um and so
I don't understand why we are walking
back from this I have heard no
particular compelling reason uh why we
are walking back from this the only
reason I seem to discern here is a
desire and a hope
on the part of some to save money on
this that's the only reason I can
discern um because the nurses themselves
are in support of maintaining the
credentialing as it currently exists and
helped play a major role in designing
the credentialing so I'm sorry that um
the committee seems to be moving towards
um adopting what they believe would be a
cost saving measure um which could be
potentially and I hope it never comes to
pass um at the expense of the children
for whom the nurses are responsible
thank you thank you very much
representative you're welcome
comments anybody out
there okay uh not seeing any other
further discussion or comments uh we'll
move into the uh taking action on on
this bill and so uh 349 a bill relative
to certification requirements for school
and nurses the motion is ought to
pass representative cordelli yes
representative B yes representative
Galler yes representative leus yes
representative Mett yes representative
Hobson yes representative Andress
yes representative
for yes representative Leon yes
representative s yes representative
miler
he's
muted Miler I'm sorry yeah no
Representative luno no representative
shw yes representative Cornell no
representative
Tanner no Ellison no Mullen no le no
wood
no 12 eight and represent lad yes and
representative
lad
13 got a shadow in here okay uh that
takes us through the last bill which
we're going to be doing right now I was
hoping that pardon me Minority Report
yes who will be doing The Minority
Report re santner are you gonna be doing
that yes I will thank you yes I will
thank you I already emailed you m okay
and we're going to break right now for
lunch and we will be back to start this
up again at 1:30 when we start working
on 607 hearing that and I go I'll go
through the the uh script again seeing
that we will be hearing and there will
be public testimony thank you very much
see you at 1:30 well get an hour yeah
[Music]
got don't any heat in
here how come even though
you
all right
Goode
all
right
for
okay
e
whoa well I've been I've been
I've been through there you see
the
oh
so are you done for the
day yes
L good
new
kind of wonder
why
there is on the front
[Music]
por not
EX I
guess
this
good
yeah
for
e
all
right
for
yes
um
[Music]
e
are we on now we're on we're on yep okay
uh I'd like to welcome all committee
members back to the hearing for this
afternoon this is the education
committee um we will be uh addressing
hb67 prior to my starting this because
we're now in a hearing rather than
executive session I'm going to read the
uh script again seeing there was an hour
break as chair of the House Education
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with the rule house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to the executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing of bills referred to the
education
committee executive session on pending
legislation may be held please note that
there is no fiscal location for members
of the public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with the house
rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email HCS l.st do. Us in the
event that the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and re
scheduled I want to introduce the staff
that are on the
meeting on the meeting assisting us
Jennifer four committee research please
note that all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done pip by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their presence please
to also State whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
law
okay under right to no law uh Madam
clerk would you please take the the the
attendant role yes representative
cordelli here in the uh conference room
committee room excuse me representative
bone here con representative Howard here
in the committee room with nine other
esteemed
colleagues representative L here in the
committee room repres in the
house representative hson here
representative Andress here in Salsbury
Home Alone representative Ford home
alone in Chester
here representative L here in the
committee room represent
SES Miler here in Kuka New Hampshire and
I'm here in my office
alone luno
Hopkinson representative Shaw here in
the committee room representative
Cornell
here representative
Tanner here in uh snowy
snipy
Ellison here my home in conquered New
Hampshire I'm alone
represent here alone in Bedford in the
basement represent LE here I am in
Jaffrey New Hampshire and I am
alone wood
here Senate chy New Hampshire with my
wife in the room and my dog representa
black here in the committee
room all present thank you very much
Madam clerk so the bill we have this
afternoon is HB
607 this bill is establishing local
education savings accounts for students
and with that I'd like to welcome the
prime sponsor is represent reveal here
um we're looking for representative
Braille uh on a telephone line and I see
a telephone line that's not the same
number I have so I've
unmuted uh telephone number 119 I'm
wondering if this is um representative
veral you can speak if that's
[Music]
you representative Virgo is connected by
um computer you could see if maybe he
sorted out his audio
issues do you see him in the in the list
yep I promoted him just now okay thank
you you
are he's
muted are you a good afternoon good
afternoon can
you oops un yeah speak one more time see
if we can got you he please okay there
he
goes he unmuted and then REM muted there
we go can can you can you hear me now
yes we
can f
fantastic so thank you um and good
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record I'm
representative Kevin verbal of
Rockingham second district and I serve
the communities of candy at Deerfield
and Nottingham uh first a little
background on me I'm a New Hampshire
native I was raised in pem New Hampshire
where I attended pem public schools from
grade eight uh grade one through grade
eight I attended Bishop Brady High
School in conquer I received the
Bachelor of Science in physical science
secondary Ed with a chemistry option
from pumma State College that sort of
shows you how old I am I attended
graduate school at Tain University in
New Orleans Louis
lisiana I held an experienced educator
certificate in physical science and
chemistry from the New Hampshire
Department of Education and I was
certified to teach grades 7 through 12 I
was a high school science teacher at
North Andover High School and North
Andover Massachusetts and at Hollis
Brookline High School in Hollis New
Hampshire I'm currently the technical
director at Summit Packaging Systems in
Manchester New Hampshire so you can see
I am a product of public parochial and
secular schools and for the record my
children attend the local public school
in Deerfield New Hampshire where I
currently
live House Bill 607 is relative to
public
education and before we can discuss
public education we should Define what
public education is public education in
New Hampshire means that each local
community has an obligation to educate
the children in their community
inherent in this responsibility is the
Public Funding for the education of all
local
children so when we speak of public
education we are speaking of who is
responsible for financing that
education that is what today's
discussion is all about it's not about
the where the community will provide the
education it is not about how the educa
the community will provide the education
but rather
how they will fund
it this should not be a discussion about
this school or that school or this
method versus that method those things
are for a separate
conversation before we get into the
particular details of this bill I want
to I want you to consider the
following there are no public schools in
New
Hampshire that's right there are no
public schools in New Hampshire what we
have is large number of private schools
that have been granted unilateral claim
to public education
monies let's consider my hometown of
Deerfield as a case and
point the Deerfield Community School our
local public school is not really a
public school it is not available to the
general public it is in fact a private
school for children that live in
Deerfield if your child does not reside
in Deerfield it is all but impossible
for your child to attend the Deerfield
Community
School Deerfield is a small school
district we only have the one school so
it would be fair to suggest that it does
not provide sufficient evidence of the
previous claim fair enough so let us
consider a larger Public School District
such as conquer Manchester Nash
Etc many school districts have more than
one and often several schools that teach
the same grade levels within their
Community
boundaries but those schools each
providing an education for children of
the same grade levels are not freely
available to all the children in the
community that currently use those
grades children must attend the school
in their District assigned to them based
on the child's home
address so if you live in Manchester and
you live on the west side and you want
to send your child to the beach Street
Elementary School you can't do that the
Beach Street Elementary School is for
children that live around Beach Street
so um it's an important thing to keep in
mind so those schools aren't really
Public Schools those schools are private
schools living in very specific and
limited
areas it's an important notion to keep
in
mind as as current and modern thinking
on education is to provide that which is
in the best interest of the student
right that's current thinking and
education is to to to provide that which
is in the best interest of the
student and it's hard to imagine that
requiring attendance to a particular
School based on a student's address will
provide students with the education that
is in their particular and individual
best
interest it's also also interesting to
consider special education in this
discussion children in the special
education system each receive an IEP
individualized education plan to ensure
that the child receives an
individualized education that is in the
best interest of that
student further those requiring the most
specialized individual education plans
are often sent to or tuition into
private schools usually out of District
that are capable of providing for the
needs that are in that child's best
interest so the concept in practice of
using taxpayer education Monies to send
students to private institutions for a
public education is still a commonplace
practice in fact my home of Deerfield
has a public school for prek through
grade eight we do not have a high
school there is a high school in our sa
our school administrative unit but the
Deerfield School District does not send
more than a few students there and they
attend under special
circumstances manifest hardship or best
interest of the
student we tuition all of our high
school students out of district and out
of ours to receive their secondary
education so uh Deerfield has a contract
with conquered high school with the
conquered School District to educate um
our high school
students school choice is nothing and
and that hasn't always been the case
Deerfield has contracted with other
schools in the past and had all kinds of
different arrangements so school choice
is nothing new what we're about to
discuss is who should be allowed to make
that decision who should get to make the
choice for a particular student and
that's what I hope we'll be discussing
today so House Bill 607 establishing
local savings accounts for students stud
is enabling
legislation in New Hampshire we value we
treasure local control and have a long
history of supporting legislation that
grants our communities local control and
local
decisionmaking this bill grants local
control to decide if local education
monies should be allowed to follow the
child the mechanisms contained within
this bill already exist and can be found
in existing
rsas first the question is defined in
the bill shall we adopt the provisions
of RSA
194e to allow the establishment of a
local education Freedom savings account
program in name the
district this ensures that the question
is stated clearly and concisely and
cannot be altered for any
reason the repeal language is also
defined in the bill shall we resend the
provisions of RSA 194e is adopted by the
local put in your school district on the
date of the adoption so that a local
education Freedom savings account
program will no will no longer be used
in the
district so it's not a one-way Street
this is this is for a community to be
able to decide to opt in to this program
as well as subsequently potentially opt
out in the future the enactment or
repeal requires a 35ths 60% super
majority vote in the affirmative by the
local
voters this sets a reasonable threshold
for a community to make this decision
and it is a threshold that is used in
other existing ballot measures already
in New Hampshire
RSA so if you're familiar with what's
commonly referred to as sb2 versus
traditional town meeting right this this
is the same mechanism that a community
would use to decide uh whether to
transition from traditional town meeting
to sb2 form of government or to
transition from sb2 form of government
back to traditional um town meeting so
there there's no precedence really for
for this
mechanism the threshold to place the
question on the ballot is low and this
is by Design to ensure easy access to
enabling local
control again these thresholds already
exist in other statutes there is no
value in setting the bar artificially
High uh a barrier to access to a clear
and succinct question to discern the
will of the people on such a matter and
so if you're looking for a reference of
where this may already exist in law if
you look at uh the statutes around uh
citizen petitioned warrant articles uh
you'll see that the thresholds are very
similar to that existing RSA again um
we're not really setting precedent with
that with that
mechanism so now the question is what
exactly is on the table this
bill simply stated allows a grant of 85%
of local regular education monies plus
90% of State monies specifically the
state adequacy Grant and differentiated
Aid to follow the child in a district
that chooses to adopt this
program as with current state adequacy
grants and other state funding into
local school districts the calculation
of the grant this grant the local Grant
is based on the previous year's School
District budget and student population
so it lags a year right just like most
of the state funding to the
schools the reason for this is to allow
for the budgeting of the grant amount in
anticipation of the school year it is
granted and so what that does is it
allows um a school board a school
District to know what the number is for
the coming year so they can add that in
their in their coming budgets it it
gives them transparency um of what's
coming
up the grant is calculated as follows
all local monies raised by
taxation minus all special education
spending so special ed is special ed
spending at the local level is
completely carved out of this this bill
doesn't do anything to touch local
special ed um monies okay um so it's uh
local monies raised by taxation minus
special ed from the previous year
divided by the previous year's average
daily membership and attendance and
that's a a population number uh
published by the State Department of
Education and then multiplied by 85%
that gives the per pupil Grant
this allows for school districts and
boards to be able to anticipate and
budget for the program when crafting
their budget it provides them a dollar
value certain per
student 85% of locally raised regular
education funding would be available to
follow the child that chooses to enroll
in the program and
15% remains with the
district again special money special
education monies are left intact and
untouched Federal monies are also left
intact and
untouched a student enrolled in this
program would no longer be counted in
the average daily membership and
attendance
calculation and therefore All State
monies associated with that child would
cease to flow to the local school
district after the first year of the
student's participation in the
program for that reason this bill also
allows 90% of the state adequacy Grant
and differentiated Aid to follow the
student so if a community enables this
program and a child avails themselves of
the program once they leave the district
the state money would go away anyway so
there's no sense to just allow the state
money to follow the
student so let us place this into um
some
context the Deerfield School District's
20 2020 2021 budget was
13,531 4 five
13,531
421 we subtract the federal funds
budgeted at
$266,800 M
33,2
44 to arrive at a total budget of 10
thou
10,231 286
we divide that by the 650 students in
the district to arrive at $1
15,740
that per pupil student amount is then
split 85 to 15 so 85% for the student to
arrive at a student grant of $1
13,379 and
$2,361 remains in the
district the first year Grant for each
student sets a minimum Grant threshold
for the
student so the grant amount is calcul
well let me just go with the script
because I'll repeat myself this provides
families with a minimum threshold dollar
amount so that families can also plan
and budget for the future with a minimum
amount of certainty so they once they
have that dollar amount they'll never
fall below that the grant amount is
recalculated annually and and may
increase or decrease year toe so there's
a certain amount of float but a
particular student's Grant will never
drop below the dollar amount of the
firste grant so the first year Grant
sets a minimum threshold for that child
so that the family has a minimum number
that they can budget and and plan
with further if a community repeals the
program at some point
all participating students are
grandfathered in until they no longer
meet the requirements of participation
is stipulated in the
bill this is intended to Simply provide
families with some certainty after
freely choosing to enter into such a
program it does not seem fair to me to
pull the rug out from under a student
that has chosen an alternative path so
if a community enacts it and a child
avails the student avails himself of the
program uh and the program gets repealed
that child gets to follow it through
until he graduate high school time out
or or leave the the
district the bill has the potential to
save District's money although that is
not a reason it is not a purpose nor is
it an objective of this bill this bill
is to provide options to families for
the best interest of
students we likely will not know for
several or many years after enactment if
this model will save District's
money but if families do not expend
their entire Grant providing an
education to their children then all
monies remaining after the student is no
longer eligible to participate in this
program will be returned to the local
school district so if we imagine a first
grader going into to this program and
staying in this program through high
school and say on average they only
spend 90% of their Grant every year uh
the money that would acre over those 12
years um would then revert back to the
school district uh once the child
graduates from high
school a large part of the discussion on
House Bill
20 which I
support was that the grant would not be
sufficient to allow lower income earners
to access other educational
options well I would pause it that every
little bit helps to be sure this bill
directly addresses that issue and would
provide a grant sufficient to allow even
the most economically challenged
families to access a broad spectrum of
alternative
opportunities that being said it would
be a shame if the B if the debate on
this bill devolved into a discussion of
class
conflict public education is providing
the funding for the education of all
children of a community using public
resources all children should have the
same and equal right to lay claim to an
equal share of the publicly raised
regular education funds regardless of
their fames finan
status after all we don't charge rich
kids more money to attend a local public
school we don't means test to be able to
enroll in a local public
school if the community chooses to allow
local education Monies to follow the
child why would we alter that fair and
Equitable access social
contract there's been a lot of
discussion relative to the expected
effects of school choice on local school
districts but let's consider some
facts I believe that most families the
vast majority of families prefer that
their children attend the Local District
school I believe that's true for a few
reasons first and foremost most families
want their children to be raised with a
sense of community with a sense of local
belonging and for their children to be
connected to their community most
families want their children to know
their
neighbors The Local District school is
often the most efficient way of
achieving this
goal that is a reason most families want
their children to attend the Local
District school second is transportation
in New Hampshire we require district
schools to provide student
transportation to and from local
district schools through grade
8 this is not an insignificant benefit
for most families attending their local
District
school a family that chooses to leave
the district for whatever reason
independently or under this program
would lose the benefit of free
transportation for the sake of brevity
lastly most families believe that their
local District school provides a good
education for their children why would a
family choose to leave a local District
school if their needs are already being
met but the fact of the matter is no one
school can provide what is in the best
interest of every student in the
district there is no one-size fit all
for some students an alternate
opportunity is in the best interest of
the
student we should always strive for what
is in the best interest to the
student New Hampshire has some of the
best public schools in the country no
one refutes that
fact but looking back at the data going
back as far back as 2008 to current
those are the numbers I could find
looking at kneecap looking at smarter
balance and looking at the New Hampshire
Statewide assessment system assessment
results New Hampshire Public School
students as a group rarely break 50% of
students at or above
Proficiency in English language arts
mathematics and
science this is a fact Stark and
stunning
fact so while we may have some of the
best public schools in the nation we are
still on average missing the mark for
half of our students for half of our
students and for science the numbers are
actually much worse than laa and
Mathematics so when we talk about
accountability you know where's the
account ility for for those children
that that aren't making that proficiency
Mark it's interesting to note that once
a student enters postsecondary education
in America that's college and university
we then transition to 100% school choice
environment and look how good that
system works the diversity in schools
and programs is all but unparalleled and
meets the needs of almost all
interestingly we do not try to block
taxpayer money in the form of pel Grants
and student loans and other financial
assistance from flowing to private
colleges and universities or to
religious colleges and universities this
program is little different than those
with where we allow taxpayer Monies to
go the allegation there'll be an exodus
of students from the local school
districts to other
opportunities is not a possibility at
least not in the near future the reason
for this is
simple there are essentially no
available slots in any non-public school
in New
Hampshire so today if I wanted to pull
my kids from public school and send them
to private school I would be very hard
press to find a seat in any private
school whether it be religious or not uh
for the education of my children they've
all been taken during the last year is
parents seek out other options that best
fit their needs with respect to the
responses of
covid-19 there is no available inventory
except for
homeschooling which is an option but an
option that does not work for the vast
majority of families God bless
homeschoolers it's it that's a high bar
and and they do a great job most
families have have double working
parents and they simply cannot choose
that option for
themselves it's not re it is not
unreasonable to fact that the inventory
of available slots in other education
settings will increase to meet the
demand but that process will take
time Market forces are wonderful things
to determine customer demands if a
district school sees that it is losing
students to other educational settings
then that is an indication that they are
not providing the product they are not
providing the service that their
customer base desires if this occurs
then the district school has one of two
options stay the course and lose more
and more of their customers to the
competition or retool and provide the
product the service that their customer
base desires this is a critical feedback
loop that is currently missing from our
public school system because we have
continued to winnow our Public School
System into such a tight
Monopoly let us consider some of the
likely critics of this bill there there
are people against this bill um and I I
don't don't deny them their right to be
against it but we should consider uh
backgrounds and motivations the teachers
unions are almost certainly going to
come out against that
bill but that is because the bill has
the potential to threaten their ability
to attract customers to attract members
the firefighters union represents
firefighters police union represents
police the teachers union represents
teachers that are members of the union
nothing more nothing
less does this bill pose an existential
threat to teachers
unions not likely but this is not a risk
those that earn their living for work
from working for unions want to
take the school boards Association will
likely come out against this bill but
that's because this bill has the
potential to threaten their Monopoly
control contr of local public education
monies these groups are likely oppose
this bill strictly from a
self-preservation motive and that should
be
considered those that will Oppo oppose
the bill because they do not want their
tax money going to private or religious
schools need to realize that this
already occurs don't get me wrong I I
appreciate their right to oppose this or
any Bill I just want to make sure that
we appreciate their potential bias and
motivations for opposing the bill
this bill is a pro- student Pro public
education and pro best interest of the
student bill this bill represents a
Quantum step forward in the continuing
journey of American public
education the American public education
system is a wonderful thing to be
sure but American public education is
and should continue to be a lot more
than just a local District school let us
do what is in the best interest of New
Hampshire children New Hampshire
students and not confine ourselves to
what is in the best interest of a
particular institution or
building but rather what is in the best
interest of our students and our
children public education is after all
the Public Funding of the education of
our children
this bill respects that fact and will
likely provide us a stronger and more
robust public education system in the
future Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for your time and
consideration and I will be happy to
take any questions that you might have
thank you very much representative rille
uh are there questions of the
representative from
members
you
recognized uh thank you Mr chair a
couple questions for
you you have I'm uh referring to page
four at this point in
time and you talk about uh school and
providers of Educational
Service that is not defined anywhere in
this file what is a provider of
educational service can you define that
since it's not defined in your
definition
section yeah thank you Mr chairman thank
you uh representative Mila for for the
question um I'm sorry can you just give
me the line where that's found I just
EXC excuse me it's page four line
29 yeah so schools and providers of educ
Educational Services I I think a school
we understand what a school is is that
correct that's correct I don't I don't
know what the other means yeah so the
provider of Educational Service is a
pretty broad term uh not formally
defined in the bill and and certainly
you know we could consider doing that uh
but when we think about um tutors when
we think about uh online learning
opportunities um Hands-On uh type
learning uh opportunities uh Cooperative
uh education um situations uh it it goes
to educational opportunities such as
that that may take place outside of a
traditional school thank you followup
please yeah I would I would suggest that
you do have a definition in that if you
if you want to pursue that because it's
not in the bill the second question I
have is similar to what we we had in the
conversation with uh
hb20 my sense is just my sensus is that
an individual could take one of these um
vouchers from a local school district
and there is no
anti-discrimination language in this
bill so in essence they could take
public monies and go to a school that
does discriminate based upon you know
religion gender Etc is that
correct thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Miler for the question
well first of of all um if we're really
going to have an honest conversation
about this we we need to be honest about
what the program is and what the program
is not and the program is not a voucher
program right this does not this program
does not meet the the definition of a
voucher this is a much broader much more
versatile much more Universal type
program uh than what a traditional
Voucher Program um is and provides so
with all due respect I would I would ask
that we we at least call it what it is
or at least avoid not calling it that
which It Isn't So it's not a voucher
program um second of all you're you're
correct the bill is not loaded up with
anti-discrimination uh language and so I
would I would contend that it's it's
probably not required although I would
certainly be uh you know amendable to a
friendly uh Amendment uh if a school is
able to operate legally and uh you know
is allowed to operate under the New
Hampshire Department of Education uh
rules for accredited schools then I
don't see um why we would want to uh
fill this bill with a bunch of uh legal
regulations that already exist and
govern those uh those schools and
institutions U just a just a a comment
please uh you can call it what you want
I'll call it what I think it is and I
continue to do that uh the Dilemma that
we have is that unlike another uh other
opportunities for kids to have uh these
tax credit uh programs this is public
money not private money that is going to
potentially a school that has
discriminator practices particularly I'm
thinking of those schools that would uh
deal with u the gender issue and that's
that's a real concern of mine I don't
think taxpayers want that to do that but
thank you very much for your time Mr Mr
Mr chairman can I respond to that please
yes go
ahead yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Myer I I
certainly appreciate um your position so
the what I guess what I would point out
is
that the the money is public money for
the education of a child and what this
bill allows is for that money to
potentially follow a student so that a
student and their family could Define
for themselves what's in the best
interest of their student there is no
guarantee with this program that any
child that wants to go to any school uh
will be accepted into that school for
whatever various reasons that that may
be perhaps the the child doesn't meet
the minimum academic threshold that the
school um is Desiring there maybe maybe
the the school um you know for whatever
reason so the this is a a free choice of
families of children to be able to take
money and seek out alternative education
environments that are in the best
interest of their child of their student
to get that child the best education
they can that may not be available in
the Local District school and right now
right now the only option other than the
Local District school for the vast
majority of families based purely on
financial reality is that they don't
have the resources to to select any
other option and this bill would make it
possible for communities to decide for
themselves if they want their local
money to be able to follow the child to
make available those other opportunities
uh for families that otherwise simply
could not afford it um and again I the
the number of students that would have
Avail themselves of this program I
believe um would be small for the vast
majority of schools and if it's a very
very large number for a local uh
District school then the Local District
School uh probably has some some inward
looking to to do about the product
they're providing thank you Mr
chairman thank you are there further
questions of the representative
representative wood represent
wood thank you Mr chairman
representative thank you for taking my
my questions um I found your
presentation um interesting seriously um
I appreciate the time and effort you put
into it uh I just have a couple uh itty
bitty uh direct Point questions I may
I'm looking Uh Kevin on page two line
16 when you talk about payment with
me yeah okay thanks um I'm talk you're
talking about payment to a tutor
um is there any qualifications for that
I mean if I'm a homeschooler can I can I
pay my sister or my
family uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you uh representative Woodcock for
the for the question
um yes I believe I believe that that
potentially would be possible okay
follow I I don't I don't know that
that's disallowed in the bill
okay fall Mr chairman thank you very
much yeah represent two more just say
thing I'm not trying to Blindside J all
just questions on um line 21 you're
talking about uh education certified or
licensed educational AIDS I don't know
what a certified educational Aid is and
what they'd be getting paid to
do uh thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
representative for the for the question
um so uh certified educational AIDS or
paraprofessionals these these would be
people um that would hold um particular
professional certifications from
organizations to provide um certain
types of uh educational instruction or
therapies right so typically um
certification programs are to
demonstrate uh Proficiency in a
specialized area or to uh highlight a
particular expertise in a professional
area and so um that would simply allow
for for those people with particular um
specialized um knowledge based
instructional methods Etc uh to be able
to be hired for this I think when we so
I I don't want to put too fine a point
on it because the bill is designed to be
written very very broadly to allow a
very broad spectrum of possibilities
okay A lot of times hold on a lot of
times your certified par professionals
and educational AIDS are people that are
associated with particular um parts of
special ed uh education and um dealing
with special education uh
needs the final question by m Mr the
chairman once again nothing nothing
point just trying to clarify Uh Kevin
you go to line down on the same page
line 34
please yes sir okay I'm looking at 33
and 34 and and I want to make sure I'm
understanding this as I read 33 and 34
that says to me if I have a student and
I maybe all wrong in this that's point
of clarity if I have a student or young
my my own youngster who's going to a
school under your plan they can come
back and play sports or be in the
science club yada yada yada at the high
school they had attended previously is
that
correct uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr Woodcock for the qu
representative Woodcock for the question
that's that's an excellent question so
um the the short answer is yes and if
you'll um if you'll bear with me I'd
like to flush it out a little bit so
that that currently exists um in in RSA
right so uh if if one chooses to
homeschool their child today um you have
availability for that child to play in
the uh local school sports teams
extracurricular uh Etc in fact if you
send a child to a um Charter School an
out of District Charter School you still
retain that access to um to sports teams
and and other things so it it simply
this is this is just to be very clear in
the law that if you Avail yourself of
this program that doesn't uh cut you out
of those benefits that we're already
providing others that have chosen to
leave the Local District school just to
followup Mr shair and last one
representative I understand that um
thank you that that's partially
informative the the second part is my
question I thought under your plan if I
leave the school district I choose to
leave the school district I am out of
the school district unlike a homeschool
who still enrolled in school
district so when I say that you're out
of the school district you once you once
you enter this plan just like a
homeschooler you would no longer be
count Ed towards the average daily
attendance for the purposes of
calculating um a state adequacy Grant um
and obviously any potential
differentiated Aid that might follow the
follow the
child but I could take that's okay I
could take advantage
ofes right yes I could okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much uh further question thank you
representative
and
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative verville for taking my
question so I I I just for the sake of
Simplicity sake let me just make sure
that I understand um what the process
looks like each eligible student would
uh clim to 85% of the money that is
raised locally that would ordinarily be
used within their school district to
educate them and 90% of the state
adequacy money is that my my numbers are
correct 85% of their local 85% of what
it would cost the Local District and 90%
of the adequacy
money yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative Mullen for for the
question um yes that that is correct so
it's 85% of the local money so 15% of
the local money stays in the Local
District school um the 90%
um was was set because there's um if you
know if you've been at this for a while
you recognize a lot of this language
from what was lovingly known as Senate
Bill 193 from three years ago and it was
set at
90% um I had I had a feeling although
not direct knowledge that uh a very
similar Bill to um the former SB 1993
would be coming forward and so I I I
assumed that they would remain at that
90% for the state monies so um yes there
is a little bit more money staying back
with the Local District um to you know
to cover whatever various expenses and I
wanted to make sure it was consistent if
another bill um should should pass and
become law so this year you know that
bill is obviously is House Bill 20 okay
so thank you for that so uh I'm going to
make up a figure because I know that the
figure is going to change from District
to District in terms of the 85% so let's
say that the total monies that a student
had at their disposal was
$155,000 where where are they going with
that money where if they're no longer in
their public school system are they all
taking that 15,000 and going to a
private school and paying tuition are
they trying to get into another Public
School are they putting it towards
homeschool costs or all of
those thank you for the question
representative that that is a fantastic
question so the the answer is you you
arrived at the answer at the very end
right so this this money goes into an
educational savings account for which
the family can withdraw um to pay for
Educational Services to provide an
education for their child and what that
would look like for any individual or
any any family uh will likely be uh
different so yes a family a family could
could take this this $15,000 and apply
it directly uh towards tuition at
another school and when we say another
school that's basically any school right
so um perhaps well deerfield's a bad
example we we are a little bit unusual
and our student enrollment is continues
to increase um so we would not accept
students in under tuition most likely
but if we imagine another town in my
district um Candia New Hampshire Candia
New Hampshire has a wonderful um one
through eight or k through eight uh
school and their population is way down
they would love to accept students under
a tuition agreement I think to keep
their their facility closer to uh what
its capacity was designed to be so it
could be another uh Public School it
could be a private school it could be
home school it could be uh online
education it it could be really any uh
combination of those of those things so
it it it really opens up some very
open-ended educational possibilities for
families uh representative one last
question on this this train of thought
anyhow um so are there Provisions in
your bill for uh somehow or another
monitoring how the money is being used I
mean how who's who's keeping track of
how and who and is that up to the family
or is it up to a scholarship
organization or the doe
or thank thank you for the question
representative it's a great question um
it I have to admit my eyes are not good
and the font is small on the bill um so
I will I will talk globally instead of
trying to find specific language and and
that'll save us some time um the the
bill would transfer the money the school
district would transfer the money to a
scholarship organization the state would
transfer their portion of the money to
the scholarship organization and then um
it's that account that would be drawn
off there are and when when you have
time to read the bill more thoroughly
you will find that there are Provisions
um for auditing of the spending of the
money uh and auditing of the program to
ensure that this money is being used for
uh approved
educational uh needs and requirements
and that if you are found to be out of
bounds on any of that you are you are
out you're ticked out of the um out of
the program and uh remaining monies
would revert back to the local school
district and uh presumably uh Court
action would follow to uh to recoup any
any monies that were um
mismanaged but it relies on a
scholarship program one one last
question Mr chair I promise so in in
looking at this auditing who who sets up
the requirements is it
the representative Mullen we've had a
number of followup questions of we have
so many people that want to speak I I I
will defer to my colleagues Mr chair
thank you very much representative Le
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my questions
uh before I proceed I will announce that
it is my Declaration of intent I am the
President of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire and it is my
intent to participate in this in
accordance with the informal resolution
of legislative ethics complaint
2019-02 um contrary to the uh um sort of
motivations that were imputed to me by
the prime sponsor I just want to make
clear that my primary motivation and
position on this bill shall be
determined what I believe by what I
believe is in the best interest of
public education in New Hampshire just
as I believe that the prime sponsor is
motivated in the same fashion and in the
same way now to my questions
um the uh scholarship organization uh on
line on page four uh lines 156 can
accept gifts grants of any kind from any
public or private entity to carry out
the purposes of the chapter um my
question here is are there any
guidelines as to how they would spend or
distribute such
monies uh to those who are participating
in the program because this would be
above and beyond uh the uh money's
deposited in an
EFA um and also as to whether or not
there is any
audit particularly an independent audit
of the scholarship organization itself
not the efas but the scholarship
organization itself as mandated is is is
any such audit mandated in this
bill uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
uh representative Le first of all um
Please be aware that in my uh opening
remarks I was speaking to no particular
individual um or about a particular
individual but simply making it clear
that certain people come at things from
certain perspectives and I was not
speaking of you specifically or any
other person specifically uh for the
record you know I was once a member of I
was once a member of a teachers union
right I was I was a dues paying member
for for many years while while I was a
teacher and and I still have a dues
paying member in the in the household
today so U don't please don't take it
incorrectly so um I I I will
confess um that there there is there is
not definition in this in this
particular bill as to um how that money
would be dispersed or used by the
organization it is but this line is
simply to make it clear that the the
only source of monies does not have to
be uh the state portion of the monies
nor the local education so that if
somebody uh wanted to make a charitable
contribution uh to the organization for
for the for their purposes um that would
be um completely acceptable uh I am not
a um Financial expert to say the least
um so I'll probably be working so I'm
very old because of that that fault it
is my understanding that um these types
of organizations are governed by
Internal Revenue Service um code and so
my my assumption is that these
organizations have to provide a
financial audit uh in order to make sure
that they're complying with the with the
law so I would expect that that um that
portion of the operation of the
organization is uh is governed by
federal law uh more so than uh State
Authority thank you representative and
and Mr chairman a
followup thank you um the eligible
students um and I'm I'm looking now at
the front of the bill so this is back um
on I suppose it's page one um l starting
at line
10 um but I guess the most important
piece there is just eligible student
means a resident of a school district
that adopts the provisions of this
chapter who is at least five years of
age not more than 20 years of age who
has not graduated from high school and
is uh currently attending a public
school cleaning a chartered a
kindergarten student or receiving home
education so uh I guess I have uh two
sort of questions based on this I find
it interesting that
a going forward a student can utilize I
just want to be clear on this going
forward a student can utilize the EFA to
pay tuition towards a private school but
a student currently in private school is
not eligible for the EFA is that
correct so the way the law is written is
you have to be um either a a member of
the school of of age um or or a
homeschool so if you are currently
already in a private school correct you
are not uh you are not captured in this
in this bill okay and final question um
I know that you had some uh data that
you had worked up on um I think your
hometown of Deerfield and the number of
students um how many students currently
uh in Deerfield are
homeschooled um and would be eligible
for the EFA and what would be the amount
of money then that Deerfield um would be
subtracting approximately from its
budget for the following
year so that's a very thank you
representative for the question that's a
very good question and that is not an
easy um answer to arrive at as I'm sure
you are aware um because there is no uh
requirement any longer that a
homeschooling family uh notify the Local
District that's my understanding that
they may choose to to notify the
Department of Education
uh in Li of um of their local District
uh homeschooling numbers
uh from an informal perspective right
because I've been after that number for
quite some time actually for for other
reasons um it's it's a very interesting
subject because certain communities have
much higher rates of homeschooling than
other communities and it's not clear to
me what what drives that um and so I
can't give an honest answer I don't know
for sure I could guess I could give a
guess number um based on people I've
talked to and what I'm aware of but I
would I would prefer not to to guess um
in a public hearing but certainly if um
if you wanted to pursue it further as a
private discussion I I would entertain
that so one of the difficulties then I
guess would be trying to estimate what
the uh impact of this would be upon any
local um Local District including your
own at this point because we don't have
those numbers is that correct
uh I don't don't agree with that so I
believe that if a uh so for a local
District such as my own or any other
they would have the number of declared
homeschoolers in their community that
notified to the Local District um I
would assume that if an inquiry was made
to the Department of Education not
necessarily for names and addresses uh
but for the number of students
participating in homeschooling um that
would have a home address within the
district uh that number could be
generated rather quickly from the
Department of Education and that would
give you a maximum number of potential
participants um you know as we heard
with House Bill 20 um there's a
significant portion of homeschool
families that probably would not be
interested in participating in these
programs for various reasons so you can
worst case it to say every homeschooler
would come into the program uh but I
think I think testimony that we've heard
indicates that that would not uh that
would not be the be the fact be the case
thank you thank you are there further
questions we have others that would like
to that are out in the general public
represent Mullen
is Mullen has raised her hand
again M you got your hand up but you've
asked quite a few questions already and
we do have I do I I just the only reason
I'm uh asking for permission to follow
up uh Mr chair is because representative
verville sort of pointed me to the fine
print and uh so I just wanted to ask him
a follow-up question based on what he
had shared with
me repres do you have that response to
that H well I'm not sure what her
question is to be honest with you Mr
chairman my question has to do with we
were discussing representative thank you
very much for indulging me here uh we
were discussing the auditing portion of
the program and who would be responsible
for
Monitor and I think what I have
discovered in the bill is that um it's
the Department of Education that would
be determining whether or not somebody
is uh compliant that could move remove a
student if they were
non-compliant that would do an annual
audit to all of those things are on page
four in your bill um so my question to
you is have you uh worked with the
Department of Education to determine how
many people it would take to be able to
staff the
program at their thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Mullen for the question
um the specific question that you just
asked me I did not ask the Department of
Education um I certainly um did review
uh draft language of the bill um with
the commissioner of education and and
others uh in that department uh to make
sure that they were uh aware of it and
so that they would have the opportunity
to provide input if they chose to um or
potentially raise Red Flags uh Before
the bill was filed so you know obviously
I don't want to Blindside the department
with uh with something that's going to
be overly combersome um so I didn't ask
that specific question they didn't they
didn't raise that as a concern with me
um so that's really the best answer that
I can provide you oh that's fine thank
you so very much for taking my question
thank you my pleasure thank
you I I would like to now start if we
could um with others who would like to
testify that are on the house remote
testifying sheets um are there any more
questions possibly from an individual
who's not spoken as a Committee Member
at this
point not seeing yes I have a I have a
point of information for the chair yes
yes so so as we're um I think
transitioning now to uh to taking
testimony from members of the public I
was wondering if um if members of the
public would be able to have access to u
to the signup sheet so that U uh people
who believe they've signed up could
indeed confirm um that uh that they're
on your
list
the house cler us be taken of midnight
last night yeah what I'm being informed
that the house clerk we've already met
with the house Clerk and the house clerk
is addressing this issue we do have uh
sheets in front of us we do know that we
have on the written testimony sheet
people how how many I didn't hear we do
have on the sheet that I've been
provided here I'm holding up of course
you can't see it but it's there that we
have a total of supporting this uh 36
people opposed to 658 neutral to and
those wanting to testify
16 now as far as those that during the
course of events that maybe stick their
hands up in the attendee list I don't
there now and we have one attendee at
this
point okay so I just want to confirm
then that that anybody that accidentally
might be uh uh not called is going to
have an opportunity to um to uh testify
that's always the case all they have to
do is put their hand up thank you Mr
chair you're welcome okay so the the
first person to testify thank thank you
very much uh representative
rille thank thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee I I
appreciate the time uh and I appreciate
the attention and I certainly appreciate
the questions I'm an easy man to find if
you have questions later please uh Reach
Out directly and uh contact me thank you
Mr chairman thank you very much so the
first person to testify is Brian baly
and I cannot find him in the list so if
you're under a different
name uh Mr DH might I'm not sure if
that's in the same Department okay so
all right so um move down to the next
one go to the next person there next
person is anarie bfield and I will
promote her to panelist the next person
that's on the list fact on the top list
right here was anry
bfield okay so go ahead Amry okay thank
you um I guess it helps to sign up early
moves me to the top of the list can you
your volume sure
as I
can yes gotta go a little higher Amory
okay is that
better yes good afternoon my name is
Amry Banfield and I'm an advocate for
parental rights and academic excellence
and education today I do come here to
testify in House Bill 607 I did sign in
as neutral on the bill however I do
support the essence of what HB 607 is
trying to accomplish the only concerns I
have would be that HB 607 needs to carve
out a provision that protects the
autonomy of the private parochial and
homeschool
Community if that is added to the bill
as an amendment it would be I would be
in support of a to pass on House Bill
607 uh I've heard opponents of school
choice legislation bring up the
importance of accountability and I would
agree that accountability is important
especially to parents I would agree that
if you speak in terms of local control
that's exactly what accountability is
supposed to do allow for the local
community parents to hold their
institutions of learning
accountable let's not seek to hold
private parochial and homeschools
accountable to the state but instead
trust parents all children who are not
served by any educational institution
should have the ability to find a school
that serves their needs not just
children from wealthy F families so when
it comes to school choice oftentimes
there are two sides
those who want to focus on school choice
and those who want to focus on the loss
of funding but there are many of us like
me who understand the value in a
balanced approach to improving the
quality of education for all children
many of you know me as a strong advocate
for public schools in New Hampshire as a
researcher of Public public education
the consensus has been that parents want
their children to attend their
neighborhood public school just as the
sponsor mentioned everything that I have
read when you offer good quality Public
Schools that's where parents choose
that's where they normally want to send
their
children that is why it is critical that
we make excellence and education public
education a priority right now a school
superintendent can redirect public funds
to private and religious schools if they
feel the child would be better served
outside that Public School District
that's an example of all stakeholders
coming together to prioritize the needs
of the child
this is why I also supported parents
when they spoke out against education
reforms like Common Core parents want
their children to remain in the public
school system but could see the serious
flaws that came with the new standards
they wanted their children in their
public school and found a way to improve
the quality of Education unfortunately
their desperation fell on deaf ears and
many of those parents did remove their
children from the public schools so
those who say they want everyone to work
to make Public Schools better watch
parents give that their Valiant effort
this is where we are falling short
seeing good parents stand up to push for
excellence in their Public Schools but
then not receiving enough support to
help them make those improvements how
can you say that you support public
education then turn your backs on
parents who are putting in the efforts
making our Public Schools the best in
the country would still be our FOC
should still be our focus and I haven't
given up when we work together to make
the public schools great parents are not
forced into looking for other options
now that many of our schools in New
Hampshire have closed or are offering
hybrid hybrid learning parents are once
again fighting to reopening their public
schools for their children I'm involved
with these groups of parents throughout
New Hampshire every day I hear from
parents in some of your districts
sharing how difficult the shutdowns have
been on their
children so sa so safe it needs to be
open safely some children are doing well
under these circumstan an es but there
is a large population of children who
are not my priority is quality Public
Schools but when children are suffering
I will not ignore their voices and I
encourage you to not ignore them either
right now parents want their children in
front of a teacher and not a computer
screen right now they want their kids in
a public school but like Common Core
they are finding out that those who want
to support public education are again
being
ignored school school choice options are
needed for a small number of children
during normal times those families need
to be heard and respected you represent
all families in your District the need
is even greater right now due the
shutdowns once schools open and if they
return to a model of Excellence many of
those children will return I know these
parents they want their kids in a public
school no one should fear though helping
children who need help right now when
public schools are at their best parents
will choose them for their kid kids I'll
give you an example prior to Common Core
Massachusetts students were competing
with children in the highest performing
countries because the focus was on
offering parents the best public schools
in the country parents wanted and
appreciated their Public Schools even if
there were other options for children
who needed it the public schools were an
excellent choice for their children and
parents knew it if you talk to them they
knew it you don't force parents to stay
in a school that is not working for
their children you find ways to improve
the school so that the public school is
their Top Choice you don't ignore
parents who demand better standard for
their children you don't ignore parents
whose children need in-person
interaction with their teacher instead
of through an iPad you act that's
supporting public schools and that's
supporting parents finally during his
Connecticut confirmation hearing M
Miguel Cardona the newly appointed US
Secretary of of Education in the Biden
Administration responded to a question
about charter schools by saying Charter
Schools provide choice for parents that
are seeking choice I think it's a viable
option and according to edweek Cardona
has been affiliated with new leaders
where he participated in a fellowship
program new leaders Embrace Embraces
school choice new leader CEO Jane Des
rvin said Miguel cares about kids who
and kids who attend public schools and
he wants to do everything he can to set
those kids up for Success that balance
perspective is what he will bring to
this role so we can see that in this new
Biden Administration officials are not
taking taking a hard ST stand against
school choice but instead have taken a
more balanced approach it was during the
Obama Administration that large sums of
federal dollars were sent to New
Hampshire and other states to expand
Choice through charter schools so I ask
you to take a more balanced approach to
educating children K to 12 this
shouldn't be an issue of one side versus
the other this should be everyone
putting aside partisan views and
supporting parents who need that support
for their children whether it be for
funding improving standards opening
schools or even offering other options
for their children when you put the
needs of all children above partisanship
you can say that you are working for all
your
constituents uh and I I thank you for
your time and that is all I have to add
for this thank you very much um I'm I'm
gonna set it start from this point
onwards I'm going to try to set a time
limit here uh because we have people in
in the Q or in the attendee list
starting to put hands up as well as
those which are already submitted uh
request to testify so we'll we'll go to
three minutes right now and we will have
an individual here in the committee
starting to
uh keep track that time and give me the
signal when it's uh the three minutes is
up uh thank you very much
represent Miss
B okay next we have uh Michael betet and
Michael you've been promoted so you can
go ahead and
speak everybody thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak on this I just
wanted to to U ask a few things and and
make a couple of very quick statements I
understand my time limits first is is
that I'm very concerned the bill doesn't
offer any prohibitions that I could find
in my reading of it that would prohibit
individuals from double dipping
insurance reimbursements for some of
those services along with their grants
I'm also curious to know how hb20 should
it uh become um law would couple with
this particular uh bill can you double
dip if you will between those two
accounts and potentially double the
monies uh that are associated with that
that's something that I didn't see any
specifics to within the bill I perhaps
maybe just missed it I think I'd like to
take one moment just to rep to speak out
directly to a comment made by
representative veral when he was
speaking to the issue of standardized
testing and accountability I think the
majority of my colleagues wouldn't be
speaking about the accountability of
State Testing in reference to the
accountabilities that are associated
with this particular bill I think that
standardized tests have made themselves
well known to be um very poor
correlators of predictability of success
for students particularly in New
Hampshire is as probably representative
Ville himself could to test um his
success probably uh would speak to that
I don't know what a standardized testing
was but certainly um there's plenty of
data out there that speaks to the lack
of correlation between those two fiscal
accountability is the issue of concern
for us I think that when you look at the
the ability to be fiscally accountable
within this bill there lacks a a very
large number of Staff members at the doe
that would be able to uh effectively
prohibit fraud most important of this uh
for homeschoolers you know when we start
looking at the reduction of adequacy
funds that are associated with this bill
and others um potentially within my own
school district of kar we're looking at
the reduction of about $1.3 million from
the state's adequacy pool uh as a result
of if all of our homeschooling students
alone you could add another
$650,000 to that number should the 50
students uh that are uh taking Char
private school enrollments right now
cash in on those particular bills so the
large number we're talking 1.5 to$ 1.7
million dollars of adequacy funds that
we drain from the state certainly are
going to be uh Amplified against the
total volume of students uh in the state
and that's just going to exacerbate the
already um woeful conditions around the
state relative to school funding um and
lastly I think I just want to make the
point if I may that we've been you know
very very very cautious about looking at
making long-term decisions about
covid-19 and how covid-19 should be
looked at through the lens of choice
through the lens of vouchers through the
lens of other opportunities I just would
ask us to all to be very cautious about
applying long-term thinking around Co 19
and the decisions that districts have
had to make to stay viable um during the
pandemic please don't use that as an
excuse to make bad legislation thank you
thank you very much are there
for not seeing hands up thank you very
much next is okay U next I was looking
for Cynthia Finn and I did not see her
in the list um so I went down to our
next elected official James oconnell I
don't see in the list so I am looking
for uh Kevin
gravy and I did see him in the list so
um did he just raise hand
he okay so go ahead Mr Brady welcome Mr
Brady
see Hello can everybody hear me now yes
yes okay great yes my my screen went
blank there for for just a second um Mr
chairman ladies and gentlemen of the
committee thank you very much for the
opportunity uh to give you some
testimony today for the record my name
is Kevin Grady and I'm a 22-year
resident of the town of hooks at New
Hampshire and uh I think that I have a a
different perspective maybe on some of
this than some of the other speakers
that you might have heard from um I was
a 25y year Air Force veteran spent the
first five and a half years of my time
in New Hampshire as an airline pilot and
then I finally took a job teaching in a
public high school down at Alvin High
School in SAU 81 in Hudson New Hampshire
teaching Air Force Junior RC for 11
school years so my perspective is a
little bit different from other folks in
that I didn't spend my whole life in
Academia only about 25% of it um I was
not in a union at any time when I was
there so I don't have any preconceived
not Notions about how any of this ought
to work and additionally I've never had
any children or grandchildren in the in
this in either private school or public
school in the state of New Hampshire so
I'm trying to be as as uh um as kind of
uh well let me move on um the I'd like
to give you just a little bit of a
cautionary tale for my 11 years uh as a
as sort of an impartial juror down in uh
in in at Alber High School in husin and
I love time my time there and my
colleagues uh were great but Hudson is
in the top
15% uh in the state of per capita income
and yet they spend the the bottom 5% on
their teacher salaries and the result of
this is that every single year for the
11 years that I taught the school board
budget didn't pass and the reason it
didn't pass is because a very small
small small percentage of the folks went
out to actually vote for this thing and
because it didn't pass the the budget
line pretty much stayed flat and because
it didn't pass we ended up with being at
the the teaching Academy if you will we
get a brand new teacher out of college
and we'd spend two years or so three
years working with them and mentoring
them and then they would leave us for
another school district I say this is a
cautionary tale because if you start
taking fairly large amounts of money out
of the school budget to fund these other
priorities what's going to happen is
you're going to do less no one in the
history of the world ever did more with
less you're going to do less with less
so at our public high schools that less
is going to start with things that kids
kids like to do that enrich and enhance
their their success there like sports
like clubs like extracurricular
activities and eventually we could get
to the point where we're having to get
rid of everything that isn't a State
graduation requirement at at a school
and that's not really very good public
education the final thing that I want to
just kind of mention as in in and in
closing is that there are there's no
Financial note attached to this thing
right here and when I listened uh to
representative verbil talk about this he
talked about sending as much as
$113,000 of of money out of a school
district uh towards this program well if
the financial note for for CAD Bill 20
which I do not support either if you
look at that there's some certain fixed
costs that are associated with actually
having a school district and they run
for some school districts up to
$113,000 so it's not going to take very
long to put a fairly sub substantial de
dent in your school funding if you start
taking that kind of money out of it to
give it to people that want to send
their children to another
school and so um in closing I I urge the
members of the committee please please
please do not Advance this bill out of
committee until you see the fiscal note
from the the Department of Education and
the finance folks and make sure that we
understand exactly what we're voting for
here thank you thank you Mr chairman I'm
done thank you very
much next next speaker is Scott gross
I've promoted you are you prepared to
speak yes I
amot thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee my name is Scot
Ross and I'm a resident of gtown New
Hampshire um I was in the private sector
as a manager for an insurance company
for almost 30 years and I've been a
business administrator for sau9 for the
last two and a half years I'm going to
focus my comments uh on two areas one as
a business administrator and secondly
just as a taxpayer um on page three of
the bill it talks about the computation
of local education funds and um I first
want to also want to thank
representative reveal for a very good
presentation and uh his work on this
bill um I will say though that as a
business administrator someone who has
to actually look at the law and apply
the law to formulas I found it very
confusing um and when you talk about
that would be lines five through 11 on
page three I came up with very different
numbers when I ran those numbers I um
and I would suggest that if you do
proceed with this bill that you use
common um terms that are used with a Dr
so if you're talking about a local
education tax effort then please use
those words I'm just simply trying to
make it easier for those like myself who
might have to apply your formulas um
wasn't sure also if if Food Service
would be subtracted from this um because
you talked about uh in the bill it talks
about monies raised by taxation I think
of a total appropriation which includes
General funds uh um Grant funds and also
Food Service funds and it was kind of
that was absent from it um so again I
would ask you just to put more clarity
around that one because again your
numbers and the numbers that I ran um
they were vastly different
um so again that was one thing um on
page four um on this will be line number
28 conduct an annual audit of all
accounts of eligible students if you
could put more clarity what type of
audit is that a financial audit uh if so
is it an independent Financial audit and
again I know those comments have been
made before about anytime we're using
any type of taxpayer money um I do
believe that there should be independent
Financial audits of all entities
involved
um as now speaking as a as a taxpayer or
just as a a private citizen um I always
worry about bills and un unintended
consequences and this would be a
question for a representative reveal um
if hypothetically I was someone who
loves sports and I am someone who loves
sports um would it be possible for
students or for uh schools to recruit
say um you know certain basketball
players football players Etc to go to
another public school or private school
and if so could an unint an unintended
consequence of this bill mean that there
could be recruitment of athletes going
to Local Schools meaning that could a
town like gtown High School uh could we
recruit the best football players in the
state and would that U monies from those
individual school districts go to us and
simply uh for that purpose so I will
leave it at that I do believe that this
bill although um I think the ptions
might be good by um representative rille
I just think there's a lot of um issues
that arise that I think need a lot of
clarity so thank you very much
appreciate it thank you very much Scott
and appreciate uh your attention and
providing us lines and page numbers and
issues which uh it points people in a
right direction thank you very
much next speaker next speaker okay next
we have uh Hester Kennedy and you've
been promoted are you there Esther thank
you everyone for taking my testimony
today I will be speaking to you on
behalf um as an individual but I do
represent um the Guilford School
District as a student service director
and I also have um on Portsmith city
council as a city
councelor um I come to you with
questions about the bill um in listening
to the evidence at the beginning of the
presentation by Mr or representative
rille um he talked about the special ed
and as you as you know as a student
service director I'm very concerned with
that but as a student service director
I'm also concerned with many of our
children who are on 504 plans and that
has not been discussed I'm also
concerned with many of our children as a
student service director we have
students in
esol and that has not been
discussed I'm also concerned with the
fact that you know we talk about
students that have stable families that
can make decisions about this um and use
the funds but who makes the decisions
for foster care
children when it comes to looking at
education for this
program what I did not see in the bill I
did not see anything that talks about
how are we going to evaluate whether
their educational experience is
successful we talk about finances in
this bill but we don't talk about what
the outcomes are going to be for
students that go to placements that we
have no knowledge of and lastly what
happens when a student goes and only
goes for a couple months or ends up in a
situation and because of their behaviors
they are kicked out of their situation
and go back to the school that will
accept all children our Public
Schools what happens to the funding how
do that work I don't see anything like
that in here when we see our Charter
Schools many many of our schools um have
students that go to Charter Schools or
have gone to Charter
Schools unfortunately some of our
charter schools accept students and then
the students don't meet their
expectation and quite often it's
behaviorally and then they get sent back
to the public school so what happens to
all that money who takes care of
that and I'd like to finish today with
talking about that
5% I truly believe that that money that
our tax pay payers um have raised by
their local property funds they have
chosen the school they wanted they come
and vote they come and pick who they
have as administrators and whether
you're in gford or in Portsmouth or in
other parts of the state people are very
active in their Community but one of the
things that I saw on the bill is you're
taking
5% to take care of these
funds is that is that an unfunded
mandate I'm just asking thank you for
your time I know we're in hard times and
I'm really proud of the Guilford school
for being full in since September and
we're doing great jobs with our students
so I'm hoping that we can get these
questions answered and I'm hoping that
you think of all children thank you for
your day or for your time
today right on the money with three
minutes good
job next we have Margaret dry maret
youve been promoted welcome to the
education
committee thank you very much for the
record I am Margaret dry and I live in
planfield
my family saved our town of planfield
over 4,00,000 by homeschooling all nine
of our children through High School from
the time our oldest started High School
to the time our youngest graduated the
tuition at our area agreement school
which was Lebanon High School jumped
from 7,000 $300 to
15,600 at an average of about $1,000 a
year times nine kids times 4 years of
high school each our savings to the town
took place while we were still paying
our entire tax bill with no tax
relief while all the while planfield
families who sent students to Kimble
Union Academy which is a private high
school here in planfield received a
planfield exemption in their tuition to
KOA for decades our town has been voting
at town meeting for a taxx exemption to
KOA pursuant to RSA 72 col 23 KOA in
turn has given tuition credits to play
field students who opt to attend there
the amount depends on the number of
students attending every given year and
the way the amount is determined has
been modified and refined over the years
it's varied from a blanket $1,800 a
student in 1993 for example to a range
of $1,300 to $9,000 in 2007 when it was
more needs based the main purpose of the
grant was to encourage planfield
students to choose Kua and save the town
the tuition to Lebanon High School
here's what the planfield Kua study
committee wrote in 1997 about this
option considering the long history of
the use of this tax exemption by
students in this town and the large
number who have benefited from it this
committee would like to ask the school
board the Selectmen and the conquered
delegation to seek ways to expand such
educational options for students
choosing other alternative education
that was two decades ago the local
education savings account described in
this bill is one of the options we've
been looking for here in planfield since
1997 it could serve well in towns that
do not have a high school by offering an
incentive to families to try other
educational Alternatives thus saving
tuition costs for the town our family's
story is proof that Family Choice
choices
can be a financial benefit to a town
Although our choice was made without the
help of an educational savings account
think how much more benefit there could
be to individual towns if they had a a
tool like this and were allowed to make
decisions to encourage these
opportunities please vote this bill
ought to pass my written testimony has
been submitted thank
you thank you very much Margaret last
time I was at Kua was when I was playing
football against Academy student it's a
good
school okay so I was looking for speaker
uh Louise Spencer I could not find her
and Bob's Rob Spencer could not find
them so uh I looked on to Mary wilky and
she has been
promoted go ahead
Mary you need to
unmute
okay can you can you hear me thank you
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee um I'm Mary wilky I'm a
retired teacher and a taxpayer from
conquered and I'm speaking in opposition
to this bill um under HB 607 a student
from conquer taking an Esa would be
entitled to more than $8,000 a year from
our local school budget and as I
understand it another approximately
$4,000 in adequacy money um so a family
with three children could be getting
$36,000 a year um to be used for home or
private schools um that provide no
public oversight as to their quality
this is money paid by taxpayers like me
and I would expect to have some reliable
and objective way to measure whether the
money is being used
effectively supporters say that we
should trust the parents that they're
the best people to assess whether their
children are making appropriate progress
and if something isn't right they'll
take them money and goes elsewhere
that's a lot of money to just go on
trust I once taught a fifth grade
student who had been homeschooled up
until then she couldn't add and subtract
whole numbers and she was reading at a
first grade level she did not have a
learning disability she simply had not
been taught if her parents had been the
best judge of her progress they would
have changed course long before fifth
grade now I know there are excellent H
schools and I really don't mean this as
an attack on home schools because I know
people who do a really good job but um
and I imagine people might say that my
example is a fluke but how do we know
there's no objective data collected
about how uh collected by the state
about the performance of homeschooled or
privately educated children a parent
satisfaction survey conducted by the
organization that hands out the
scholarships is not
enough I know that sometimes children in
public school fail too but there are
accountability measures in place
including Statewide assessment results
that are collected and publicly
disclosed taxpayers with concerns about
the quality of their Public Schools can
weigh in and push for change via their
elected school boards if our money is
going to be used to send students to
home schools or private schools then
those same accountable accountability
measures should apply to them and those
who are providing excellent education
shouldn't B with
this and just one other issue that came
up earlier when um one of the
representatives asked about
discrimination issues and I believe that
representative verville um kind of
focused on the child in that situation
and was saying well children will be
able to find what what suits them and
what what works for them but I'm looking
at it from my point of view as a
taxpayer um if I understand that private
religious schools are allowed by law to
discriminate based on disability or the
other way to say that is the laws
preventing discrimination based on
disability don't apply to private
religious schools they can also
discriminate against students who are
gay so if I had a child with a
disability or a child who was gay my tax
dollars would be subsidizing a school
that my child would not be welcome in
and I find that um very troubling as
well thank you very much for your
time thank you very much Mary appreciate
you okay next we have H David
Dy you've been promoted so you can
unmute you go hi good afternoon uh
chairman lad members of the education
committee thank you for your time today
I'll be brief um I wanted to register my
opposition to this bill I appreciate
representative verville's presentation
and the time he put into it although I
do have to respectfully disagree with
some of the points that he made um as
you may remember um when I identified
myself last week on
hb20 and a I'm a former uh School Board
member in Pembroke and I'm currently on
the budget committee I'm not speaking
for either group today I'm just
representing myself but um during my
service on those committees I found how
difficult it is to keep Public Schools
solvent um in the circumstances we're in
New Hampshire where public schools are
woefully
underfunded so I'm probably going to
oppose anything that is going to
further uh reduce funding for those
Public
Schools particularly um bills that take
public money and give them to students
to use in private schools are for other
educational
purposes um I have problems as been
stated by many other speakers with the
accountability issue the discriminate
the Discrimination issue um but my real
concern is to funding issue and um I I'd
just like to encourage them the
committee to uh uh to to look at bills
that might uh help the underfunded
public schools in New Hampshire come up
to some kind of fair and Equitable
funding for all
students um that's pretty much why I'm
here today and I uh I appreciate your
time and um that's pretty much all I
have to say about this so I just
encourage an itl vote uh on HB 607 thank
you very much thank you very much
representative and representative moff
would like to ask you a question if
that's okay
sure yeah hey uh honorable uh Dave dhy U
you mentioned discrim discrimination and
several others today have mentioned
discrimination schools that
discriminate um in there's a couple of
all girl schools there's one in the Anon
there's one up in Jefferson uh do you
think these are discriminatory
schools I'm I'm not familiar with those
schools
representative uh so I I guess I I can't
comment on them but I do know that that
there are many private schools that have
qualifications for students um I
actually have worked in private schools
in the past and I know that U they don't
take uh any student that applies um for
any number of different reasons and I
find that um that's fine that's that's
within their right to do that but um
public schools have to accept um all
students and educate all students and I
think that that's a a real distinction
uh that we have to look at carefully so
I'm I'm not sure if I answered your
question uh but thank you for thank you
for asking
it yes thank you for your answer I my my
sense is from hearing uh you've
mentioned discrimination and others have
mentioned that my sense is it's a
pejorative and uh and that's just my
concern here is that if someone wanted
the the girl school in anim is very
small for special needs girls and if
that's a school that's the best school
for a young girl uh the notion that it's
discriminatory because it doesn't take
boys uh that's that's that was my
question for you and and for others
because you're not the first one that's
brought that up uh so thank you for your
for your
answer you're welcome thank you very
much okay thank you very much uh
honorable
Dave have a good thank you next we have
Becky Wilson from the School Board
Association you've been promoted you can
unmute good afternoon everybody um I
actually had registered to testify for
the New Hampshire school boards
Association in anticipation of Barett
Christina not being available but I
believe he is available and has his hand
raised if you could promote him okay um
he wasn't scheduled is it okay Barett
Christin Barett yes that's bar I'm sorry
thank you so
much okay um good afternoon Mr Christina
you can go ahead and
uh thank you very much um representative
Hobson chairman lad members of of the
committee uh thank you uh for the
opportunity to testify this is bar
Christina executive director New
Hampshire school boards Association we
are opposed to House Bill
607 uh I'd like to comment um or respond
to a couple of comments um that were
made by by previous speakers um
representative vervo you stated that
there are no public schools in New
Hampshire um the New Hampshire Supreme
Court has said otherwise um The
Claremont decision is pretty clear about
what the obligations of the state are to
fund a public education to include um
accountability measures within public
education so on and so forth um you know
I I as reading through the bill it it
dawned on me it's not a direct analogy
but it's somewhat similar we had
something similar to this when the
charter school bill was first enacted um
I believe in in the mid90s RS RSA
194b uh that bill contained a actually
that law does contain a provision
whereby local voters through the warrant
uh process and warrant article process
can adopt and Implement a charter school
within an existing public school um
voters after that bill was adopted
voters you know ran the numbers looked
at the process looked at the programs
and realized they were going to be
paying for the same system twice that
was why local voters to my knowledge
have not approved any Charter School
schools um across the state I know we
have a couple of the one in Dairy next
charter schools within I believe the
dairy one of the buildings I don't know
how that was approved though but we've
been through this before um voters
looked at it they ran the numbers and
they realized that they were going to be
funding the same system twice so I look
through this bill and I'm thinking to
myself we're going to be giving
$133,000 for students to actually leave
the public school to fund another option
whether or not that's homeschooling
whether not that attending the private
school um it doesn't make good fiscal
sense it doesn't make good policy sense
and we've tried it once before um with
the charter school with the when when
Charter Schools were first being
implemented in in New Hampshire um and
the last comment that I would like to
make um to representative Moffet you
mentioned that it's a a pejorative um
when um opponents of these voucher bills
use the dis discrimination aspect that
that private schools are allowed to that
the private schools are allowed to
discriminate and you said that's a Prive
um the other Prive that is common
through all of these voucher bills um
and all of these bills seeking to
privatize public education is that the
money should follow the child the money
does follow the child through the
funding system that we have in New
Hampshire it's called the Statewide
educational property tax if you live in
Deerfield you pay the swept and that's
going to fund the deer for school system
if that family has three children and
they up and move from Deerfield and move
to hook set guess what they're paying
their swept when they move to hookset
that's the money that we use that's the
funding system that the legislature has
chosen um to use to fund our public
schools to meet its Claremont obligation
of funding public schools which do exist
um
so those are my comments on the bill um
I it it it's a bad policy there's no
fiscal note I why we can't get fiscal
notes on these bills before they coming
to hearing is significantly frustrating
um especially in times when um taxpayers
are crying for property tax relief
especially at a time when um our schools
are in flux due to covid so uh nhba is
opposed uh to to House Bill
607 um those are just a couple of the
reasons that nsba opposes this bill um
but with that I'm happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
thank you very much are there any
questions for the school boards
Association
I don't see any hands thank you very
much
be okay uh we have Lisa white she is
super I think she's superintendent of
school
region You' been you've been
promoted hi yes thank you um thank you
uh representative chair lad for the
opportunity to address the committee uh
my name is Lisa wit I'm the
superintendent of schools in the manad
Regional School District um I did want
to Echo um one of uh baric Christina's
comments and also the um the ba from
gtown um regarding the calculations um I
ran my own calculations and they also
seemed not comparable to what
representative Ville um had listed so at
the very least the the mechanism
described in the bill is is confusing
and I share the frustration with not
having a note to analyze prior to coming
to
hearing um representative veral also
mentioned when he introduced the bill
that um a student wouldn't be included
in the ADM so the adequacy it could be
diverted to the educational savings
account but I didn't see a provision in
the bill that actually requires a
student to withdraw from the public
school system to actually access the
fund so a student could still be
enrolled in the public school system and
accessing the public school resources
while at the same time using funds for
other Educational Services which we
heard could be tuition could be online
could be Transportation could be
tutoring um a district would still be
required to provide services for the
enrolled student so for each student who
remains in the public school for whom
there is a voucher account that is being
accessed the funds raised by public
taxation are on top of that which the
district would already be raising to
educate that student which I think
Barrett also highlighted in his
testimony is um you know could be a
costly
Endeavor um I also want to be clear um
representative verville that the
department of education does not
accredit schools there is a process for
public school approval and there is a
process for private school approval
there's actually two tracks of private
school approval private schools can be
approved for attendance and they can be
approved for their programs and in New
Hampshire sure the number of private
schools that are approved for attendance
only outnumbers those that are approved
programmatically 2 to one um and so but
in those private schools that are
approved for programs in order to be
approved as a program they have to seek
accreditation from an outside agency as
part of that um and so just to be clear
there is a difference between approval
and accreditation and what that means in
New
Hampshire additionally I wanted to
address the the issue of discrimination
and just to be clear that private
schools do not have to follow
anti-discrimination laws or the
individuals with disabilities Education
Act and their admissions procedures so I
I I I've heard it said before and I
completely agree that many private
schools are inclusive and do not
discriminate but I think it's
unconscionable to think that our state
would allow public dollars to perpetuate
discriminatory practices by institutions
who can use any criteria that they wish
to pick and choose who they will or will
not admit as
students all of that um based upon all
that I would urge you to reject or to
move that this bill is inexpedient to
legislate thank you for your time thank
thank you very much
uh you you want to take any questions or
are you good I'm happy to take questions
if anybody would like to ask
questions not seeing any
hands thank you very much
Lisa
okay we have uh one
attendee who uh I believe is not oh I'm
sorry did I get everybody oh Brian
Hopkins yes he's Brian you've been
promoted can you hear me yeah Brian um
I'm noting that you signed up in support
did you hit the wrong button nope I did
hit the wrong
button okay thank you very much Mr
chairman
um uh I wasn't trying to throw you throw
you for a loop there um oh you
didn't uh thank you very much uh for the
record uh Brian Hawkins I'm here
representing Nea New Hampshire uh in
opposition to the bill um although I
will say I am here because
not uh was mentioned earlier you know
our our members care deeply about uh
public education and every child and
that is why I'm here today um I will be
very brief because most of the uh
previous speaker has covered our
concerns uh first and foremost uh was
the the tremendous potential cost of
this uh especially to a small school
school district this could be
disproportionately uh large cost um and
at a time when you know earlier today we
there was a hearing in house finance
about uh
you know supporting school districts
during the during the pandemic for for
the uh drop in uh adequacy that they're
facing in this particular time there are
so many Financial pressures on school
districts uh that adding
this to it uh we think would not be um
good policy for the State of New
Hampshire or for its school
districts uh
especially since it uh transfers both
state and local Aid uh I would also
reiterate some of the accountability
issues U very concerned for example on
page four line one that the department
May conduct an audit of an El eligible
students account as needed to ensure
compliance with this
chapter uh and also that the uh on the
same page um it's that it's the
scholarship
organization uh
that is is auditing accounts of
students um I think that that probably
belongs either with at least with the
state or with the uh you know a public
entity because it is public dollars that
is being
used
um and then finally a lot of uh
questions around the
um the process of adopting this so you
know how this would work in a
Cooperative School District I think this
that could be very confusing especially
if uh there is a larger town in a
Cooperative School District that adopts
this uh when you know smaller town in
that District uh may not want it um I
think that could be very confusing as to
how that could work and potentially uh
an even greater burden on that smaller
community and finally um you know I
think if this is going to be put on a
warrant uh warrants include um fiscal
notes they include uh as what it's going
to cost and I don't see that um in this
bill there's no
um you know how will we give local uh
taxpayers an idea of what approving uh
something like this could potentially
cost I don't I'm not sure there is a
good way to do it and the bill certainly
doesn't outline that
um with that I'll close my testimony and
happy to take any questions thank you
very much Brian Hawkins are there
questions for
Brian don't see any don't see any thank
you very much Brian thank you very
much okay uh we have a person who's been
waiting in the waiting room I believe
she's a member of the public net dala
sorry the name cut off at the end
so if you're there go ahead and and
speak
up hi can you hear me yes we can there
we go um hi my name is Nicolet gallago
I'm in Dover New
Hampshire um I am a product of New
Hampshire's fantastic Public Schools I
went to
conal um I love that school I love the
education that I was given um as a
benefit of where my parents happened to
live and I think that my difficulty with
this bill and why I oppose this bill is
because of that experience because I had
such a great Public School experience
and I I think I'm disturbed by the
idea that folks would move to a
community be involved in it and then
take their kids right out of the school
um
I think that our public schools are a
pride and something that we should be
investing in in every opportunity and
something that our constitution
understood right that our Founders
understood and valued and um and I I'd
like to see us pursuing it from the
angle of how we
ensure every student has access to the
best education in the public school not
how do we get kids in into special
schools outside of the public school
system um there have been a lot of
questions a lot of testimony one of my
questions is actually for representative
veral um one of the things that he
mentioned very early on in his
presentation was suggesting that kids
who are in a school can't change to
another school that's not been my
experience in Dover I have uh a child in
the school and I asked if I could put
him into another school and they
accommodated that for the elementary
school so um I don't think that that's a
a uh
Statewide concern so I I I was surprised
by that suggestion I I imagine I don't
have the opportunity to ask questions
but I did want to bring it up because my
neighborhood school is not the school
that my elementary student is
in um um and yeah and otherwise I just
my my I oppose this I think we should be
moving in a different direction we
should be looking at the um commission
that was put together and the suggestion
there and they certainly didn't suggest
that we should divert public money into
private schools there's a reason for
that um and I hope that we can do better
for our kids thank you much
n okay lastly we have
uh car lad from the New Hampshire school
administrators
Association okay go ahead Mr
lad welcome Dr
Lad good afternoon thank you very much
for taking my testimony um this is the
the third time that I've signed up to
speak and um and somehow I don't make it
on the list I'm starting to get a
complex um but thank you uh Mr chairman
thank you members of House Ed um and
certainly uh thank you representative
veral uh for your testimony uh and uh
your presentation um while we understand
the intent of the bill is to expand
opportunities we really feel uh that
this bill is only providing
opportunities for some uh rather than
all uh nhsaa is going to oppose 607 um
primarily because it raises so many
concerns and questions I'm not going to
go back over all of the questions and
and concerns that were raised but but a
couple of things that I really would
like to respond to um one of the things
that um the uh representative Ville
spoke uh about is the best interests of
the student and uh ensuring that we do
whatever is in the best interest of the
student um and if that's going to be the
metric that we use then shouldn't that
be written
into uh any definition of what uh the
content of an adequate education should
be and how we then fund it uh because
the best interest of a student is not
the same as an adequate education which
is what the Constitution requires and
what is being funded so um local school
districts go above and beyond what the
state determines to be adequate um but
the the state does not so I'm I'm
interested to know if we can start
talking about costing out the best
interests of students uh rather than
just um
adequacy and then the the other piece
I'm going to submit written testimony
that goes line by line uh with
questions but one of the things that uh
keeps being raised um and and I don't
think we talk enough about this uh we
talk about public education as a
monopoly um that school choice is
somehow going to drive competition um
and that competition is the foundation
of a market economy if public education
were a commodity then I would say yes
that argument fits however public
education is not a commodity to be
traded on the open market it's a Civic
and Community responsibility to its
citizens we've enshrined that in the New
Hampshire Constitution more so than
other states um it's a contract that we
signed between the communities and the
um and the school system part of that
Civic contract that we have is a public
education that benefits all students not
just those who can afford it and not
just those who have the ability to
access these alternative opportunities
because not all students will be able to
there aren't many private schools in the
North Country you're not going to be
able to get a lot of kids out of a
public school and have them go somewhere
else it's it's simply not going to
happen so we're providing opportunities
for some but not for all and the last um
comment that I'll make um is really I
question the haste of this bill in
addition to all of the other school
voucher program bills and school choice
things that are being kind of pushed
through um is there a reason why we are
um reaching um while we're creating such
far-reaching
policy considerations on such a
shortterm basis um if these are bills
that are truly um interested in the
public good and public education
students and families and taxpayers then
we should be seeing fiscal notes
attached to these and there should be I
think maybe a more comprehensive
approach to how we're looking at it to
some extent these bills um are being a
knee-jerk reaction to covid uh because
I'm hearing a lot of uh testimony and
support of these bills because of covid
related school closures and things like
that I I'm not sure that in the middle
of a pandemic is the best time for us to
completely upend public school policy
and complet completely change it uh
without more careful thought um and some
processes in place um if we're really
interested in expanding opportunities
and choices then it would seem to make
sense that we should come up with a path
forward that's agreed to by everyone um
and right now um this doesn't seem to do
it so on because the bill raises so many
questions and I think it's really being
pushed forward too quickly without
enough time for real consideration and
debate um we respectfully urge you to
vote no on uh HB 607 thanks very much
for your time and I'll certainly take
any questions thank you very much Dr Lad
um I apologize if you've ended up last
on the list no no problem I don't mind
being last I just I just don't want to
not be called okay um I I I'm curious to
know when did you sign up because that
might be part of what I'm seeing here
some of them have been signed up for
quite a while I signed up over the
weekend okay we do have one more speaker
okay thank you very much you're very
welcome we do have one more speaker uh
representative Josh yella you've been
promoted welcome to the education
committee thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee for
hearing my testimony I am uh co-sponsor
on this bill so I would like to uh thank
representative vervo for bringing this
issue forward and as a part of this
hearing I wanted I heard some um
questions being raised which I thought I
might um bring a perspective
uh to the committee's attention
I it's often been uh mentioned in these
uh in the testimonies I've heard today
that there is a need
for the cost uh a fiscal note on this
bill and I question whether or not that
is even possible with a legislation that
is enabling because the cost
of
maintaining uh you know the Department
of Education staff etc etc will depend
greatly on how many people or how many
towns choose to adopt this
legislation and if there are no
towns like uh previous
speaker hinted might be then there would
be potentially no cost to any of the
towns or to the Department of Education
and so I just wanted to bring bring that
to the committee's attention um
as possibly not something that would
hinder uh a vote going forward and
whether or not you get a fiscal note
because it's possible that it could
range from zero to you know any amount
of money so thank you for for uh hearing
my testimony today thank you very much
representative
K okay well we have a
question
represent thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking the
question you're from Fremont I believe
so um what do you think um since any
homeschooled student would be eligible
for this uh if Fremont adopted it at any
time um let's say Fremont adopted it
next year how many homeschool students
do you estimate there to be in Fremont
and what would be the cost to your
District
thank you representative and thank you
uh for asking the question um in my
district uh as was previously mentioned
it it can be hard to quantify how many
um people are homeschoolers but
definitely there are more homeschoolers
this year than previous I think we asked
the school uh so I'm a part of the
budget Committee in my town and so I
believe we asked the school this year I
think it was me that asked how many
people had moved to
um to uh homeschooling or other options
because of uh the schooling challenges
this year and I believe the the amount
of
money is or the amount of people is
around 10 to 15 people in our town
and there's also uh in my town we are um
have a tuition contract with
another uh school for our high school
and we are in the process of um coming
to the end of that contract and want to
explore other
options because of the place that we are
tuition tuition to are very expensive
and so we are looking at our different
options and uh I
would like to be able to
propose
some options like this bill in in uh in
our town so I I definitely think that uh
our
town current uh cost per pupil is
around uh 15,000 per
per per student but that's including
special education so it's it's hard to
um know what the number would be minus
uh special education because we don't
actually deal with that in the budget
committee so thank you for the question
though thank you thank you very
much represent luno do you have a
question yes with a question for
representative
yila
so thank you very much uh Mr chair and
thank you very much representative you
talked about um looking for options um
and I was wondering if you took a look
at any of the recommendations offered by
the school funding commission that would
improve not only student Equity by um U
for for your town of Fremont but also um
also tax Equity uh equity for your
taxpayers and reduce your tax rate by
nearly $5 per
thousand thank you representative for
the question are we actually have formed
a committee to look at all of our
options and uh our that committee is
work is still in progress so I'm not
actually on that committee so I don't
know what all the options they have
considered but they are consider
considering a number of options and a
number of school districts which we may
tuition our students to but thank you
for the question okay thanks thank you
very much representative uh further
questions not see your hands thank you
very much
representative okay we're going to close
this hearing now we have no further uh
questions uh we just got one just got
one yeah uh Mr Tom St
Martin
uh
so okay we have one more just raised the
hand uh Tom St Martin Tom St
Martin I need to
unmute am I Live Now yes well thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
um my this is my first remote test
testimony in case you can't tell uh so
I'd like to thank the house and the
staff for providing this mode of
communication um realizing that I'm uh I
signed up late so I'm coming in as Tay
and Charlie and I uh have a little bit
of revision to do as I testify so uh
please forgive me if I'm a little bit
disjoint but I will try very hard to be
brief and to not repeat things that have
been said already um I am Tom St Martin
I am from Candia I am a former State Rep
having served back in the 90s though I
am appearing here today only
representing myself I am not a teacher I
have no relatives who are teachers no
descendants in public or private school
I am a taxpayer I have been and I
continue to be cheerfully willing to pay
my taxes though I have no direct benefit
I simply support public education
answerable to the public as the Bedrock
of our society I'm the product of both
parochial and public schools including a
two- room Schoolhouse that once served
sixth grades I have known many fine
teachers both public and private as well
as school board
members I thought it was very
interesting to hear the claim that there
are no Public Schools I assure you
Candia has a public school funded with
public taxes from each and every
taxpayer and with public oversight both
through district meetings and a publicly
elected school board and a budget
committee I appreciate representative
bal's characterization of our school is
excellent apparently our public
oversight is working the question
becomes why aren't we trying to figure
out why some districts do well and how
can we apply that to other schools I'm
disappointed that there appear to be few
attempts to directly improve our our
public education system instead we focus
on kicking the can down the road to the
perceived Panacea of competition please
note that I'm not advocating the
anything for the perennial school
funding issue I'd like to see us Focus
as a state on identifying best practices
rather than rely on voucher programs to
evolve our
approach I'm also a little surprised at
HP 607 as well as uh HP 20 for
establishing another bureaucratic entry
entity with no apparent public oversight
to administer public funds granted the
doe is exists but I know that they are
overworked um I also do not consider
them public oversight in the way that
for example a local school board is so
uh the details of financial audits are
blurry I see no detail of any assessment
of outcomes or programs as as a whole it
doesn't seem to increase uh any
efficiency and I would suggest that it
probably will result in uh higher
private school tuitions and
administration
costs it would allow public funds to be
expended on religious schools I realize
that that has been mentioned before um
but I would point out again that that
discrimination could result in
discrimination among religions for
example uh there are multitude of
religions in New Hampshire and largely
for this reason New Hampshire has a long
tradition of not funding religious
schools nor I believe um is it allowed
under our
constitution not only is discrimination
possible on the basis of religion for
schools as a whole but it is certainly
possible on the basis of individuals and
this would be um an issue of possible
discrimination not only from private
organizations but also from the
scholarship organization itself self
again there is no public oversight and
that in my mind is the key problem with
this bill and for the for the record
with uh
hb20 I note that there is no Financial
note attached as other people have said
I do want to mention that uh
representative Kirk who was a well-known
fiscal conservative in the past did
provide a a summary of a similar Bill a
session or two ago and U his summary
might be instructive to look at in the
absence of a fiscal note which I
certainly hope is forthcoming I would
like to um thank you all again for your
time and I appreciate the fact that you
let me uh get in even though I ran in
under the wire thank you very
much thank you very much uh Mr St
Martin uh with that we are going to
close our session our hearing for
today and it's uh it's uh right now
about eight minutes or 4 uh we we had
today actually presenting I count around
16 or so
um and we had 36 supporting it this is
the sheets that we handed 36 supporting
658 opposed two neutral and 16 uh
supposedly testifying we got 16
testifying I don't know if they're the
same ones
but seven added oppose and one added uh
support
two eight
added one support a
couple okay thank you very much Mr chair
yes yeah I had my hand up but um but I
was muted I I didn't know if if Mr if um
The Honorable Tom S Martin was going to
take a
question we've we've closed it now uh
represent luno um okay um
I I I didn't hear anything I apologize
no I was muted but I had my hand
so uh with that uh I I think what we're
going to do is just close down the day
we're at the point now it's just about
four o'clock and so I will adjourn this
meeting and the next meeting we have
will be on Thursday where we'll pick up
hb20 uh that's on the docket for pretty
much you know the entire morning uh and
we may if we have time following that uh
do some executing ofs that have not been
that have been heard and we haven't
dealt with
already so with that this meeting is
adjourned you have some questions you
have some questions here wait I I did
well for one thing is has representative
veral become a member of our committee
he's still
here and and also if you remember I
asked if you had any idea of what time
we would be ending next Thursday because
I do have my vaccine appointment at 5:
so I have to leave by 4 you know do you
think we will be done by four or should
I get a
sub I I can't give you a good answer in
that representative Cornell um it
depends upon the number of people that
we we get this list the morning of um
the the testimony for that bill so
it's different than what we had from the
previous day when we had on Thursday uh
there the list is uh the goal posts are
moving all over the field here so I I
just can't give you that answer right
now I'm hoping that we could have this
done in the morning but um you know it's
something where if you do have a
doctor's
appointment um and it's five at 5
block yeah well I'd like to know the
name of that doctor maybe I'd use him no
it's to get my vaccine shot I'm getting
vac
vaccine at five congratulations um I I I
uh I can't give you an you know an
answer that Patricia I just uh I don't
know but I would suggest that we will be
done hopefully by that
time
okay we won't be doing
if we go that we'll be trying to get out
of here okay thank
youcon uh Mr chairman yes do you have
any sense of what our schedule looks
like next week or is that still up in
the
air um I I do have some rough ideas
that's something that's my homework for
this evening um but I can give you what
I have right now represent
Ellison
um find my Gra she
here
very St Louis a second
okay
whoever said computers would stop the
paperwork well Mr chairman tomorrow
would be fine if you think that you
might have more information at at that
point yeah I I've got to get that in
tomorrow I can tell you that we have
several bills we've yet to
address um the special education bill is
one of them uh I I think that what was
that 613 yes uh that's the bill where
we're waiting for an amendment to come
in where we can possibly uh address this
catastrophic Aid the special ed
component that's on that bill is
catastrophic Aid and we're looking at a
possibility of trying to get that um
Insurance Pool to try to help districts
dealing with the extravagant costs
associated with that
program
um and let's see we have uh
608 deal with that's the uh the bill
that's relative to the formula for
determining funding for Education yeah
and there's been a couple bills that we
have not addressed to this point um um
so I I would suggest that and of course
then we're going to have to have
executive sessions on both hb2 along the
lines and the bill we just did
today
so so and 110 has to come up that's the
bill that deals with the money from the
uh the doe the quarterly payments going
to municipality rather than the school
district or the district uh we have to
address that bill as well
oh and and here's exactly and I I do
have this draft sheet here in Fr me now
so on
Thursday we're dealing with hb20 as you
you all probably know when we we recess
that bill Tuesday the following week
we'll have an executive session starting
out with 613 that's the special ed bill
then we're going to have a hearing
somewhere along the way on
608 and we're going to try to get
608 um through EXA session and hb2 if
we're you know ready for it or if if
we've got the hearing done hopefully we
do uh then on
Thursday that's the 18th that's the day
we have to have everything reported by
that's an early Bill we'd still have
607 and then we have another bill 320
which is the Civics test requirement so
and and some those which we haven't done
are not early bills so we're not going
to be put to the wall to get those
things done we can hold those over so
um it looks like most of the hard work's
going to be done on that Tuesday of the
next week and at least the morning there
of uh the
Thursday thank you Mr chairman Mr
chairman qu question for the process for
for NE uh for Thursday it's my
understanding that we had what 100
people that had signed up uh previously
I'm assuming if they're there they will
have an
opportunity and anyone then who under
the new rules they have to sign up by 8
o'clock in order to also be included in
the queue of those presenters is that
right well I also understand that if
somebody is coming in like they used to
do with the pink card and drop by and
we're having a hearing we we listen to
them I'm I'm not going to say to anybody
you cannot testify so if somebody comes
in and puts their hand up and and and
gets into that queue uh we don't have
necessarily on the whatever you want to
call the color of the sheet is the sheet
that we get handed on those who want to
testify I'm going to let that person uh
testify okay thank thank you Mr chair Mr
Mr chair on 20 where we have a
two-minute rule I tried to impose
something and we gave the three minutes
today but some people went over by a
minute or so they closing their their
presentations down Mr chair yes I I
would like to know um when we're you
expect that we will get fiscal notes on
some of these things I know that um as
people have testified you know it's hard
to make any specific number but
certainly in the past the LBA and the
doe has made fiscal notes based on
estimates um and also on statistics from
other states that have Incorporated uh
similar thing to see what percentage of
students um actually are en enrolled in
um these programs so I have a hard time
voting on these when I don't know what
it's how it's going to affect my local
school district in terms of money I
don't know how it's going to affect the
local taxpayers so um could you put some
pressure on to see if we can get some
fiscal notes yeah
I I've been trying to put that pressure
on at it's just this compressed schedule
that we've been within uh that there are
number bills which we had more you know
of these early bills that had fiscal
notes or needed fiscal notes and the
department is receiving this stuff and I
can honestly say and I've seen that
people like Caitlyn are over there just
you know trying and and and Mark is
working with her trying to get this
stuff pushed out um in fact some of the
stuff still has to come from there Co to
the lb hey and and uh some of these
bills have not even arrived there yet uh
so it's it's one I've had the question
to and I recognize that um uh in some
cases we may be just dealing with the
policy side like we're trying to do in
the school building Aid right now the
policy side and then the fiscal stuff
that's going to have to be taken care of
in the next committee when when we do
have more accurate uh information it's
also like we have in the house when we
don't have all the quarterly reports
back and we're looking at our revenues
and then all of a sudden it goes to the
Senate and of course they have that
information and everything gets updated
a little bit over there so I will again
make some contacts to see and try to
move them along but quite honestly uh
they're underwater and this remote
situation isn't helping matters at all
well thank you I just um I really have a
hard time with that I I've never you
know in the three four turn now that
I've been here I've never had an
instance I think that I haven't been
able to at least have an estimate of
fiscal impact on my local
communities yeah thank you for for
pushing it so without if there are there
further questions from the committee not
see any thank you very much everybody
and have a good evening and uh we'll see
you on
Thursday we muted